what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos guys
today we have a stream sponsor so a
major airline has a privacy rights
activist disappointed after a recent
data breach turned out to be a gold mine
for hackers this affected customers and
employees of the airline because they
have their social security number
driver's license numbers and their
personally identifiable information
stolen in a matter of days several other
airlines in recent years have had
similar data breaches making me wonder
if my data has been stolen as well that
is why I signed up for virtual Shield
one identify virtual Shield ones
identity protection feature scans 700
billion data elements for suspicious
activity associated with your name bank
account and other personally
identifiable information to alert you
after a data breach it also comes with
unlimited VPN access and advanced VPN
features included malware and ad
blocking try virtual Shield 1 risk free
for 30 days by clicking the link in the
description box below and after entering
your details you'll have an
instantaneous access to all Security
benefits virtual Shield one offers guys
honestly
um
I found out that my passwords have been
leaked a lot so you should probably look
into that because I yeah
um also a couple of things for before we
start so first of all we have two clips
channels the first is just pearly clips
and the second is Pearl daily we
actually are just about to hit 200k on
just pearly clip so let's go
and guys guys thank you for 600k on the
main Channel we got 200k in the last two
weeks you guys have been mad absolutely
mad
um on top of that guys we have four
memberships tiers the first tier um you
get to be a part of the live chat
tonight the second tier you get to be a
part of our Discord and you get behind
the scenes Vlogs third tier um you get
to connect with me on social media this
means you have access to my inbox you
can ask me questions fourth tier um you
get a one-on-one call with me once a
month um so some people use this because
they just want to know questions about
the show like I had one guy call me and
ask me how I recruited we had a bunch of
questions about that other people want
to know help with their YouTube channel
other people just have random questions
to ask me it's a lot of fun so sign up
for that membership
um on top of that my Instagram is just
dot pearly things make sure you type out
the whole thing we're almost to 70k on
Instagram so go follow my Instagram and
on Tick Tock guys they took away my
first Tick Tock account they took away
my second Tick Tock account they took
away my third Tick Tock account and now
they have taken away my fourth Tick Tock
account so go follow my fifth Tick Tock
account just pearlythings.5 okay so um
today's topic
um I think I told some of you before
we're gonna be talking about modern
women love The One That Got Away so
we're going to talk about the one so
before we start though
um let's go go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and a fun fact about yourself so
starting here and then go around and
then we'll do second row
hi I'm Sharon autumn I'm 18. I'm very
very single unfortunately and a fun
facts about me is
a fun fact about me
you're an actor right I'm an actor yeah
that's a fun fact about me
hello my name is Katrina I'm 23 years
I'm a business owner and a model
hi my name is Nye I'm 24 and a fun fact
about me is I'm a radio host and I'm a
Scorpio yeah I had to get two in what's
your when's your birthday next week
Wednesday what day wait Wednesday
oh man I'm the fourth oh my God
come on
uh what's going on I'll go buy a beard
gang I'm 28 and a fun fact about me is
that I've been connecting beard since
2019.
my name is cable 31 and fun fact about
New Year's I'm an actor
cool cool
Auntie oh I'm Auntie Jenny
where am I 54 in a relationship the fun
facts about me is that I'm here
and tell them you you just got monetized
I'm on YouTube I just got one
so
stupid
watch out for the boots and Super Chat
somebody tell them what are we doing
Monday
we're doing a live podcast
isn't that the same thing yeah sorry
live calling show I'm on school
sometimes sometimes in life people just
need Auntie Jenny to yell at them so if
you want to be yelled at yeah Pearl's
been here with that today
not enough fruit not enough vegetables
but now we're gonna get there yeah she
says I need to eat more veggies
yeah just go 28
um was it fun fact fun your name is
relationship status
um no relationship yeah fun fact I'm a
Pisces okay okay
name is Rick 20 JB
oh yeah I'm single fun fact I can sing
okay can I hear a little bit
okay
I got money I got money
I'm serious
okay so um today we're talking about the
one that got away or the one actually
we'll start with the one so tell me do
you guys believe in the in the one and
tell me why yes or no
you know what yeah yes I know I'm a
little cool I'm a little bit about her I
won't lie to you so like I'll have the
one for like a month and then I'll be
like he's not even all that like why am
I moving like this so yeah yeah you're
like
I believe there's the one out there I
feel like obviously time is just the
essence so I feel like there's a
different time for everyone my best
friends Nan and Granddad have been
together for 58 years
May I'm Single Living my best life till
forever notice but when it comes it
comes but I do believe it will come okay
I don't believe there's the one because
I think you could have multiple ones
so I feel like yeah I don't think
there's just one significant person so I
feel like in your lifetime you could
have more than one the one so now how
many your ones have you had
how much time have you got
uh to be honest I feel like you choose
the one
so
yeah
or they choose you you meet that person
that um ticks with the boxes and then
you just say yep you're good to go
yeah
um I tend to agree with him I think you
choose the one because um
I mean like especially in this day and
age it's too much like we've got too
much choice and um
we can kind of like siphon out what we
want what we don't want you know we've
most of us have been around the block
enough to know like what we will
tolerating not tolerate so yeah
easy you're on the Block big dog
what's that been around the block yeah
no no you sound like he's tired
um
you know I'm not going to be different I
believe in that there's the one
that one person that
even if there was a good person in your
life like 20 years ago
even if you're with a man or woman now
that person if I say the one that person
from way back when it sticks in your
brain folks that's the one
I believe there's one for everyone
and it's lucky that I got my one I left
my one I got my one I with my one how is
there a one for everyone if there's 55
if there's more women than men on the
planet it's 55 women 45 man maybe some
of them double up in it
look how many ones she had yeah I just
said I got one she said she had multiple
ones I mean she's not good not at the
same time
yeah I mean we were talking about the
one and she was like yeah there's the
one this time I want that time one yeah
we're talking about V1 yeah she's got
five D ones right but that's how you
work out it wouldn't be the one it's not
the one
exactly but we were saying the one that
she had multiple you said you said you
believe in the one you think there's
something I do I believe that how is how
is there someone for everyone if there's
more women on the planet than men if
there's more women in plant than men
that means that some people got more
than one ones or they got the same one
some girls have to share yes
but you don't know you might not know
I don't jump from relationship I don't
jump from man I will know when it's the
right time I'm not talking about you
jumping for my man I'm talking about you
having the same man
he could be your one and then you find
that there's another woman that's been
out there 15 years and she is also
yeah so who's his woman that means
there's not one for everyone I mean it's
kind of different to women some people
just miss out well you don't you don't
think like was that a term we hear more
for women or for men yeah but that's
what I'm saying women say like he's the
one but you don't hear men say that
because men are nasty they just want to
ski you think most men are nasty I think
women women
the only way you can get a website all
men and nasty is be a lesbian
not if you're not a lesbian you can't
sit here and turn around and say that oh
man enough
you've had a nasty yeah
lesbians
that means that she's going to have
nasty men no that's that means she's
gonna have nasty men
no no no no no no she can't turn around
here and sit down and say that all men
are nasty and expect to have a man if
you're gonna turn around and say the old
men are nasty expect to have a woman
because that means that you don't want a
man because that man's gonna be nasty so
as you're gonna say that the minute
she's dealing with a nasty I can
understand oh so many nasty but I'm
gonna sit here and let a woman
not nasty some men are nasty are all the
men she's doing with the Nazis
you know what you gotta say that because
that means that he's nasty he's nasty
he's nasty he's nasty because
I have so many friends that have told me
their experiences we all have similar
experiences Echo Chambers
I'll tell you the numbers behind it one
out of three men under 30 are their
virgins or haven't had sex in the last
year most women are sexually active
women are more nasty than men by and
large just because it's because it's
because it's because women only select a
very small percentage of men on dating
apps we only swipe right five percent of
the time so the reason you think men are
trash is because you're all sleeping
with the same ones um
foreign
for me personally I feel like
you can have more than one soul mate in
life yeah but there's always the one
like there's always the one you can have
more than one soul mate but there's
always the one there's no plural there's
always like the one or maybe not always
but if you find the one there's just
that one and you know when you leave her
in it yeah when she's gone
we can find another soul mate though but
you never remember the one no there's a
difference there's a difference
you're cool if you're saying to someone
they're your soul mate that's like you
can get deeper than soulmate you can you
can how did the queen get in one song
you can go into twin flame you could get
deep in and saw me trust me
you could get deeper than something
trust me look it up there's always the
one like whether she's in your life or
out your life even for women as well
like whether they're in your life
there's always that one
nah that's not yeah
okay what do you think so my my thing is
here I believe there's the one in it and
I'm gonna know when I get that one
because that one is gonna stop me from D
my dog and [ __ ] and I want to get dinner
because I love I love loving it you know
what I mean but at the moment I'm just
living but there's the one in it yeah
I'm saying but I'm just saying something
as well like what's her name sorry
what's your name man yeah Sharon you
need to slow down with calling every man
to stink back because I know somebody I
know that's a stink back in it I know
some good [ __ ] out there I know some
man that would die for the gallery
because you're young and you're young
yeah you're younger you're still messing
with the little [ __ ] them that's
that's trying to run around and beat you
and your bedroom at the same time what
you're saying there's nothing wrong with
that man just trying to get there but
you see the thing is that what what you
like you you know sorry I I say this all
the time in it a lot of woman's got this
whole thing where they think they've
been watching Disney movies I think
that's life that's relationship that's
not relationship I ain't just women that
think that there's some men as well
I'm I'm a man I don't think like that
but okay
but in order to have a conversation we
have to make generalities and and who
watches Disney movies women or men yeah
because because by and large men are
because by and large men aren't nasty
and largely statistically there's no
piece of data that you can find out
there that says by and large men are
nasty but he didn't he didn't he didn't
generalize she said all
right he didn't say oh when he's talking
about Disney he didn't say oh she said
oh man
so out of the men and the women
I don't hear the men they're waiting for
their princess to come I'm always
hearing women talking about oh how many
frogs I have to kiss before I reach the
prince I never hear a man saying that
okay
no what we're trying to say is that
Disney don't work for men so when
they're saying about the women that gay
man you're talking about because I had
no man saying oh I'm waiting for my
princess to come okay
for the queen queen ain't got nothing to
do with Disneyland
let me speak if you ask a black man yeah
about Queen got nothing to do with
Disney yeah nothing to do with Disney
and if you ask a black woman about her
oh whenever this Frog's gonna come it's
always something to do with Disney but
you will never ever hear a black man say
that he wants a queen and an empress and
to do with Disney it's always tribals no
but you don't understand where it comes
comes from it don't come from Disney it
comes from the ancestor it comes from
Africa and that's what I'm talking about
when they when he's talking about the
girls and they're Disney they're waiting
for their prince to come and then they
turn around like the women normally do
it say oh what about the men the men's
doing it they call it a queen queen and
Disney come totally different in Disney
you got princess but you've never had a
man
you never hear a man talk about Princess
you always hear a man talk about his
queen queen
Rastafarians and the black men and the
African American right and your hearing
talking about his Queen ain't got
nothing to do with Disney but you can't
say nothing they're talking about it
but how do you know
let me get wrong with you
nothing about a queen
talk about his Queen it's his black
queen everyone talk about this princess
it's his black princess and it comes
from Africa don't come with nothing to
do with Disney and there's somebody that
said they've got Rastafarians in go and
ask your father if he's talking about
his Queen if he mentions Disney
exactly but so when the men are talking
about queen.com
she's talking about a prince will come
he's never had that though listen though
you're talking about Disney he said
where you're coming from is Disney she's
bringing up the queen a queen for a
black person has nothing to do with
Disney if he's putting the woman there
he's one of the woman dead that's his
Queen that's his Emperor this is a carry
on his chest Disney man not carried out
they want a horse to carry you they'll
carry over the shoulder on what the
[ __ ] seven doors
sorry so for me I've got a queen in it
the queen of this person that gave birth
to me in it my Empress is going to be
together you know what I'm saying yes
I'm gonna settle down within it but my I
got my queen and my queen Queen's my
mother you know what I'm saying that's
nice
well you guys are watching too much
Disney things I have a question I have a
question do you think black men are too
in love with their mums no you're gonna
[ __ ] their mothers
a black man cannot be too in love with
his mother because that is his mother he
just said that that's his Queen he just
said about not about black people
incestors
I just wanna okay let's just unpack this
for a second all right incest is a thing
yeah do you do you think by and large
it's very common in society it's not
common no okay so why bring it up why do
we bring up the exceptions
because no because she's saying that um
all that black men she's acting like she
wants to [ __ ] that that they want to
[ __ ] no no no no no no no no no no no no
and what she said she said
what did you mean by it you think black
men love their moms too much I didn't
say I think I said do you think because
I've seen I'm not saying all black when
I'm just asking do you guys think
because I've seen cases where it's like
I love my mom and I'm there's some men
that they seem like it's like their
mom's their first love like no woman can
compete obviously of course that's true
though obviously not like that like it's
a there's some have you not heard of
emotional incest like sometimes I'm not
that's not all black this is seriously
you need to stop reading books you know
I'm not reading books I'm speaking from
personal life experiences no no because
men love their mother you all right I
didn't say that I said something
let me tell you
let me share something here well you
know what your mom having you as a
single mom and bring you up in in some
[ __ ] [ __ ] environment and still turn you
into a man you're gonna
Jones how can you not love that woman
bro
that's not loving your mom too much I
said Can something how can you love your
mom too much because there's some people
have you not heard of emotional incest
how can you love your mum too much
into I'm not I asked the question I
didn't say black man do you love them
but I said do you guys think you're
confusing me now man I said do you guys
think okay let's what do you mean by do
they love their like what is loving your
mom too much give me an example I think
it's when you when you act like she's
your wife when you obviously you can
love your mom and there's like how like
exactly how can you say you can love
your mom too much but some people treat
their moms like that's that's their wife
okay they do things that they would do
to their wife so they want it so so they
give me an example give you an example
for example you see some Let me Give an
example the way they treat them like
their wife could say one thing but if
their mom says something if it goes
against what their mom said
automatically the wife is wrong that's
fair or if that's not life
disrespect
that's respect no no because I'm not
talking about respect I'm not saying
that oh I'm saying if your mom says you
told you to do one thing and then your
girlfriend your wife's your wife really
told you to do something else why would
you not follow your wife why do you why
do you want to be in a relationship
she's a good woman she should list she
should read the Spectrum you should be
listening to your man why is he
listening to you no I'm asking like yeah
so I'm saying like like that makes sense
I think it should two ways I don't think
if you're in a relationship you should
just listen to your mind because your
man should also listen to it no I think
at the end of the day someone has to
submit so it's either you or her I think
you can both be somebody
okay I have a question I want to ask the
guys really quick um do you feel like in
a relationship you can be in a
relationship with a girl where you're
both submissive no no no
I mean I'm a Madman you know just yes or
no yes or no no no no no would you want
to be in a relationship where you're
both submissive to each other no no
who would you listen to you're who would
you listen to more your wife or your
mother depends on what they're saying
okay depends what they're saying yeah it
does depend on what they say my mom was
here before any man it does it doesn't
matter whatever mom say I'm listening I
don't care
I listen to myself like even with my mom
get to a stage
where even with your mom as a woman he
tends to you get to an age where and you
kind of realize it where you've become a
man where you're even your mom kind of
turns to you as a man and she more
listens to you
yeah it works both ways okay there's two
things I want to say
number one I believe that if you marry a
woman and you start to do it in church
you've got to do biblical leave your
family behind and stick with them no
matter what happens your mother will
watch you suffer and number two I want
to ask a young lady
f
Your Man
was taking you and his mother
you're not married taking you and his
mother to the supermarket who would sit
in the front seat
because that's his mom and because I'm
African and I've been raised with
respect I would let his mom's in the
foreign
foreign
so how would you feel right if you're
let's say you and your man got a holiday
plan like a vacation yeah and his and
his mum was like like she just woke up
one day and she's like you know what
whatever your partner's name is I want
you to take me here on the day that
you're supposed to fly out and he
canceled your holiday to take out how
did you feel no no let me let me do
another way
let me turn it on his head for you let
me tell you I'm not gonna make up your
story I want to tell you no no no no
because that's a question no you're
asking me a question based on nothing
but facts enough based on hearsay or
you're made up the story but I'm gonna
tell you a story coming from the truth
okay from my experience okay I've got my
man right and I've got my mother and if
it comes to me when I go to my man's
house he puts my mother before me every
single time
food everything my mama comes before me
that man would not ever put me before my
mother
never mind
hang on a minute because he puts my
mother yeah before me I have no problem
with him putting his mother before me
because he'd done that he's already done
it and proven it annoys me because he
will tell me straight I'm getting out of
bed I'm gonna make your mom breakfast
get up do this for your mom do that for
your mom do this for your mom him and my
mum I would say I like that compared to
me and my mum okay and compared to me
and him because if it means that he has
to do making me breakfast or making my
mum he'd make my mom breakfast and
believe you me he don't want to [ __ ] my
mom and he don't see my mama's number
who said anything about [ __ ] mums
you're the only one that said that over
five times
you know what you want to do you want to
go back when you finish watch this and
Rewind and you hear me say and you hear
her say that oh don't some men look like
they want to [ __ ] their mothers right
that's where it come from the question
is that's where it comes from no no no
no no
[ __ ] men
and she said sometimes they look like
they do want to that you see them
do you guys think black men
and you're not retract right it's the
only making that like oh I'm some kind
of weather that I'm talking about
people
because you can't talk over each other
just said that she said it no okay I'm
sorry
I don't agree with it that's what I said
and I heard you say it okay okay
let's listen to each other
's gotta keep talking over each other we
can't have you on
each other it has to be one at a time
okay
okay
all right
um so I'm gonna say I I don't think most
men love their moms too much I think
it's just a respect thing like just
listening to both ends I really think
it's just like like a respecting the
older generation thing I agree yeah I
think that's where it comes from that's
fair because that's that was my question
okay okay okay yeah yeah do you agree
you agree not saying nothing
it's from style I'm sorry but I still
don't say nothing one second I'm not
gonna agree just to agree to say oh one
second one second let me say something
as well yeah what's your name no not yet
stop getting onto it stop mommy like
that I'm not getting on to her but I'm
saying you're saying about people
talking over one another but you're the
one that's talking over everyone what
did I do I put my hand up but then every
time someone tries to say something
no but you guys you guys keep
interrupting her so she'll be gone
she'll be good I'm telling you we can we
can rewind it and I I'm telling you I
don't agree
um okay well it's it's all in film so
yeah we can watch it back um okay so um
the reason I thought of this top we're
just gonna change the topic Okay the
reason the reason I thought of this
topic today
um is because of a hit Katy Perry song
okay
so
um have you who who here has heard The
One That Got Away the song yeah no you
might have to sing it can you can you
can you raise your hand if you know what
song I'm talking about
it
The One That Got Away the one that
wrecked my heart you know voice vocals
yeah
okay but so this is the lyrics all right
it says in another life I would be your
girl we keep all our promises it would
be us against the world in another life
I would make you stay so I don't have to
say you were the one that got away
The One That Got Away now this popular
was really this song was really popular
among women
um across the U in the US it was like a
huge song like I don't know five ten
years ago roughly
is there a One That Got Away for you
guys
okay this is so weird yeah because
literally I just got over him yesterday
okay like yesterday night I was really
deep in life and then this one was like
you know what okay you said you're 18
you're only 18. yeah okay I've had a lot
of like I've had a lot of experiences
yeah okay but I I think what's your body
come
because
ages here it might like for my age range
if I that makes you at home I mean as
you get older there's different
categories but oh no no that's not
flirting that's just practicing to be a
whole that's a chain you know don't you
think so you're getting getting a man to
me so you understand all man's mind work
so you want to twist them up and do your
thing with this and that that No One's
Gonna know like come on check to a
beggar man that's still a former
cheating big dog no matter how you look
at it how is it cheating if you're
single
real single so I see that's leading on
men's then because I never sometimes
yeah like for example the other day a
boy started telling me send me some long
paragraph about how he likes me this and
that I aired it and I was like oh why
like and I just like I kept owing the
question and then the other day I was
like I can't do this I don't like you
and it's like yeah yeah but like how did
I lead you on because I never
specifically said I liked you I never
backed up in the way guys look at it so
if you're like talking to them on a
regular basis it's like yeah you're like
I never confirmed it like when you said
it you may not have confirmed it but
it's still your YouTube and you're young
so this is kind of like when I was
younger I didn't really understand this
either but like men and women can't be
friends they're not your friends the
only reason they're talking they're
they're trying they're trying no okay
yeah and I promise you and I promise you
I promise you I promise you if you were
300 pounds they would not be your friend
I'm telling you I have got genuine where
friends
can I can I just give this girl a bit of
advice in future like don't introduce
yourself as a whole
I just going forward yeah moving forward
introduce yourself just for you in it no
but it wasn't a basically our Channel I
think I'm trying to explain something
you see you see this is what I say to
the man them yeah if you attract to a
gun and you don't get a [ __ ] you know
we tear out the [ __ ] off
if I don't get a [ __ ]
that's impatience
I don't believe in marriage you don't
know my age
just one thing I never do no no no do
you one day you want to settle down and
get him and get a woman yeah well I'm
not getting married so how are you gonna
do that if you don't [ __ ] you after the
first week
all right so how are you gonna find your
woman how are you gonna find yourself
so you don't care
listen you're gonna tell me that's my
attraction if I [ __ ] hard and I like I
like her but I'm gonna stay without no
girl so if you like someone so much and
she don't [ __ ] you after that Eighth Day
You're Gonna Leave Her all right I said
A week
I'll explain this to you like from the
guy's point of view like most girls from
the guy's point of view it's like most
girls there's someone you've let sleep
with you quickly at some point in your
life
it's not the point that's not the point
at some point let's wait wait okay you
got it you gotta wait at some point in
your life most girls have let someone
sleep with them quickly so from the
guy's point of view if if you're not if
you're making him wait a long time
you're just not that guy and and I do
interviews all the time with girls on
the street and like they'll like I had a
girl the other day she said she told me
if I'm at Bruno Mars tomorrow it would
be on it would be because that's the one
I think because of his Fame but I feel
like for me I've recently started
talking to this guy right and we've been
talking and I feel like I'm not ready to
give him the boom boom yet because I
want to keep him on his cell and you
know do you like him do you like him
that's why that's why let me tell you
something
but let me tell you something from a
man's point of view yeah like you could
be in a situation yeah where you've met
a girl and
she don't know about
my brother hey I don't know him off
camera but he might have done something
over there yeah but he might I just she
might not have liked him so she just cut
through her prerogative in it she just
wanted to beat so she just beat in it
I've come along now yeah she's thinking
raw
she likes him like she likes man she
wants to she don't want to come across
in a certain way to man so now she got
along at the Pom-Pom she's lying to you
so what I'm saying for my man's point of
view is like hold on a minute you're
taking man for Egypt that's how man
looks like no he's not looking at me
like that no but I'm saying in that
situation a man would look for a
girlfriend last week no but I just
wanted to [ __ ] him no but I'm not saying
you're wrong
you're using sex you're using you're
using sex as a weapon to get committed
up my people on the first night I feel
like instantly he'll be like you know
what I've had them
that's fair if you are wifey and if you
have never done that but most men like
they can kind of get a vibe from a girl
and they're like you know what she's
probably done that at a certain age
she's probably done that with someone
for free so why why am I I have a [ __ ]
for money yeah I can say that I've done
it for free whatever I've done you you
know what I'm saying though like at some
point at some point she has she has done
that for a guy that hasn't taken her on
a date
stop interrupting me you've done it like
four times if you do it again you can't
stay on okay so at some point she has
done it for free at some point she has
done it for a guy that She chased or
that that she didn't have to take that
he didn't have to take her on a date and
so you're gonna have the next guy do all
of this because of your past trauma yeah
but no I wouldn't I wouldn't just like
see a guy just because he's going to
take me on a day XYZ not every every guy
that I have seen I've been like oh let
me make him wait X Y and Z because I
like it
it's not always going back it's just
recently now that's fine that's fine I'm
saying at some point how old are you how
old are you I'm 23. okay at some point
has there been a guy that you haven't
made weight that long well I was
previously an eight year relationship
and I've got a child and I've left here
but have you had the one that's done
I've met I've met a guy once yeah and
then I've spoke to him on social media I
met him ends up sleeping with him and
realizing he wasn't the one so it has
happened
which is which is fine I'm not I'm not
saying like that you do that often but
I'm saying if you've done that once for
someone the guys see that as
disrespectful because you're gonna make
this next guy get to know you and do all
this stuff when you gave it to the last
guy
sometimes I feel like sometimes when you
have it I feel like there's levels
levels to it so if there's someone that
you genuine like there's some some guys
out here and be like you know what babes
I just want to [ __ ] I don't want a
relationship I don't want to settle down
I just want to [ __ ] and that's up to the
woman if she feels like she wants stuff
food but I feel like it's different
aspects if you're actually wanting to
get to know that person and and build a
foundation with that person but that's
what I'm a woman's point of view right
who is here to judge me if that's no but
I didn't see it yeah no but I'm saying
in general from my man's point of view
like that's why I said it's your
prerogative I'm just saying from a man's
perspective yeah this is how in general
like men look on things you know I'm
gonna say let me flip it on his head
down here from a woman's perspective now
yeah say like you're dating a man that
puts his business on social media in
terms of when he's seeing a girl you
know about his life is on as I would say
they'll go on dates he'll post it if
he's buying no things he'll post it and
he's that type of guy where he's taking
an uptown regular he buys a little gifts
regular he pulls it regular you've seen
that previously yeah him and the girl's
done now yeah you and him start talking
now so boom now you've like so imagine
now he just wants to come and chill out
your yard he's not on no I'm telling you
now majority of girls will have an issue
that could not be saying hold on a
minute I've seen you taking kaisha
Uptown
what's going on like but hold on you
just want to come around and watch
Netflix and chill and Boom Beach we beat
that hold on dead that's what I'm trying
to say so with a man it's the same thing
if a man knows a girl has like
previously and I'm not saying there's
nothing wrong with it from a man's
perspective as previously except with x
y and Zed maybe not on the first night
but you know I mean like pretty soon
first night second night whatever and
then with him she's trying to do like
the get to know I'm not saying there's a
problem with that because from her
perspective it's from the writer that
she's thinking now I want to settle down
but from his perspective you're taking
him a big dog you know what you just say
it's so cool I mentioned a few things
and I always got this thing you know
I've done this in the past I'm not doing
it again fam why are you gonna tell me
that you was home with me are you a map
I'm not involving no no you don't want
to give me the crap [ __ ] yeah I've done
that bro I mean all of it if you told me
that you [ __ ] two [ __ ] before you
better believe I'm gonna ask you to [ __ ]
a chick with me I want all of that [ __ ]
but are these women saying it just off
the gospel are you asking them the
questions
let me ask you yeah yeah so you got you
ain't got a man knowing it no I'm saying
are you [ __ ]
all right I swear I swear so cool see
it's so cool so are you chatting to a
man now uh no no no no no man you're
like you know like I'll reply to like
the hey beautiful and yeah
so that's your thing so man
complimenting that's your thing because
you're learning you said I remember that
what's up my princess is that what gets
you going nah Amanda yeah
that's the same crusty line that you use
on all women nah nah I'm a stink back
I'm the most honest I'm gonna tell you I
wanna [ __ ] oh okay it's up to you what
you want to do and how does that work
out for you it works I'm a funny [ __ ]
okay funny get [ __ ]
I make people laugh yeah you know what
I'm saying yeah but in general them
sweet nothing so what women want to hear
in general they don't they don't want to
hear the truth but in general if his
approach in general would not work the
man that say in the sweet nothings to
her you're beautiful and all that in
general that would work
nobody say in general like women would
say they want what you're saying blunt
honesty like yo I just want to bend you
over right now but hear what I'm saying
majority of time I'm sexy you know it
depends what night it is
but you know what it is
going up what you said yeah you know the
majority of girls yeah yeah would think
what you just said in their head don't
be touched but you see their response
would be different to what they think
yeah but if the Hennessy is involved
anyway but maybe because everybody
a yard man talk to a girl of course
yeah
it's kind of like it's kind of like um
okay imagine if you bought a purse right
and you've spent 500 on a purse and you
three you bought the same Pairs and I I
came in and I said I got the same purse
for 150. gasp would you be kind of salty
yeah
sex is not the same thing as mine yeah
it is
okay okay let's let's flip it let's flip
it okay as a woman
um imagine
um
okay you found out you're dating a guy
and you found out like like he bought
you let's say a hundred dollars
something for your birthday and you find
out his ex-girlfriend he rented out a
whole club threw her a whole party
invited all of her friends
how would you kick off but in my head
yeah
and at first and at first right you you
would be excited for the hundred dollar
gift and you would think oh wow this
this guy's so nice until until you find
out about his ex that he did all of that
that's the equivalent for guys
to add on to that yeah because I
mentioned something similar when I said
like you've seen a guy dating experience
online and he's doing all the Uptown
stuff then with you he just wants to
Netflix and chill at your house like
you're gonna think huh and even to to go
for that point you can take it with with
it's a it's another reason why men not
like a girl that's very active like
dating wise and sexually wise because if
you're active dating wise you're gonna
have more there's more chance of you
having those experiences where you're
getting the the big money purses and
what not and what not and it's just
natural that when the next man comes
along now you might not have that but if
a man wants to do that he would do that
no but he might not have that okay he
might not have it then that's fine and
then but but it's it's not always
fighting for the majority of women
because now you're thinking hold on a
minute I've been used to my last
birthday no but you can have your own
but on your last birthday your man took
you X Y and Z this birthday a man's
buying a Chinese saying yo that's true
wait one more for men it's like you've
had a girl yeah that is doing the most
in the bedroom like doing the most like
because you're sexually active bro then
you've got a next thing good girl and
that you like her been in the bedroom
she can't really Arch her back and then
things
you're saying bro I'm not happy with it
the experience but check it if if a girl
puts out on the first date you wife in
it yeah if the [ __ ] is good what what's
my problem yeah I wouldn't say no I
wouldn't say no but for me that's a red
flag cause you imagine what if she only
slept with you on the first date there
you go what if it was you no I was the
only person yeah first time I wouldn't
believe it I wouldn't believe it no I
understand that I like it as well you
know all the time we get into things
about the bodycon watch your body come
big dog
[Music]
one of them you know why because I can
see what she's been doing but no need
that's not it's all in the Life only
want to lie and you're walking around
town because Tom the sneak on your thumb
on the night before
in all seriousness right and this is a
serious Auntie Jenny coming on now right
because you were talking so much rubbish
earlier that when they talk about body
care I I just zoned out for the fact
that I don't want to hear what it's not
what to say but that's why I asked the
question again
for at 18 there's nothing to be proud
about right I'm telling you now I know
because when I heard the 15 before 30
that's where it starts from so as far as
I'm concerned you see your four
keep it at four to your 30. no no no no
no no keep it at four don't be going out
and I'll date some winding up the guys
don't be going out and saying oh I'm
gonna go to you just in case right
because if I was a man and I took you
out and you're not freeing it up I'm
gonna feel offended especially if you're
not going to go out for a date to look
for forward to having a relationship so
you see your four I want to hear from
you
that in five years time it's too full
unless you got a ring on your finger in
10 years time that is still four unless
you've got your finger and your ring on
your finger right and take don't shut up
take advice from an older woman that
four but 18 is nothing to be talking
about right you need no stop I'm talking
to a young lady I'm trying to teach her
from all you men out there that wanna
[ __ ] her stop do not have anymore I'm
seriously I'm not you but men in general
I'm telling you I'm serious now 18. when
you think about the legal age is 16.
please don't don't do it don't do it to
yourself I'm telling you right because
I'm trying to save you from yourself
don't listen to anybody else that's
telling you it's okay tell them that
Auntie Jenny says I've got to shut it
down from now on I tell you what you do
right DM me when you want to have sex
again and I will meet you wherever you
are oh it's right 200 and whatever miles
and stop you from having sex anytime you
feel frisky you find that you're in a
relationship with a man call me and I
will come down there and I will cop
blocks
I'm telling you because as if he was my
daughter you'd be coming home with me
now if you're living on your own I'll be
taking you home because four at 18. it's
disgusting it's disgusting
don't listen to them that other women is
good if you want to date tell them that
Auntie Jenny says I'm gonna shut my legs
when I'm on a date if you wanna date
with me just talk to me but don't have
no more sex because the people out there
and the women that are teaching you that
it's okay they're telling you rubbish
they're lying to you you know why
because they're jealous of your youth so
the only thing you got now is your Youth
and your low body count so don't let no
older woman tell you no different keep
your body cat Low by shutting your legs
concentrate on your career from now on
because when I heard four I thought
myself it could possibly be you because
when I was like oh 25 I was on four and
you're 18 on four it's not good don't do
it don't listen to nobody and I'm
telling you the truth right if I can
drive 135 miles to have sex with my man
I will drive 200 miles to [ __ ] block you
that's so funny
because that's what I wanted to say
because I couldn't believe that the four
I have to check four and check your age
again that's why I've been waiting it
all quiet because I couldn't believe
that 18 year old I had my son at your
age
and that's where it stopped do I mean
one and my son at your age and you're
having four you're gonna children stop
before you get pregnant and it stops you
don't have nothing Auntie Jenny why are
you being like this though no I agree
with you
hey no I know you're trying to shake it
off
she's not gonna do it to me my son's 37.
that could be my grandchild right now
listen I can't block him I know anywhere
you see her right any man wants to have
sex in this woman remember Auntie Jenny
be after you I've got you marked I do
not have sex in this young woman because
she belongs to me
in Texas
I have a question for you
so every question
do you think she should wait till she's
married now yes do you think
wait till she's married before she frees
it up two minutes she's had four already
yeah so as far as I'm concerned as you
can free up for four and she can free up
for five or six but what she needs to do
she needs to be careful who she frees
out for next time don't believe the hype
as they say don't believe it and then
she wants to free up you make sure that
you date you have conversations you talk
about sex you discuss about sex and I
mean every fake positions everything
because he might not be right for you do
I mean so anything you want to know
about a man whether he cleans his balls
properly you've lost everything before
you go and have sex with them then
you're sure so yes I'm turning there
lock it down and and today I'm not gonna
respect your thing but I don't respect
that thing still it's all right because
you're not gonna get this ticket
that one is that's not my status
I have a question so from a guy's point
of view right yeah why why would he wait
for marriage or for long term with a
girl that has given it up for free
before he shouldn't so then how would
that work right because maybe like I
don't know how long you waited or what
but like like she slept with four other
dudes no why would a guy like wait for a
girl that slept now what I'm trying to
say is that it's not the matter of
waiting right right it's the matter of
like 4 or 18 for me it's disgusting yeah
I agree with you so what she needs to do
she needs to hold it down so as she keep
that four so as she gets like bro 25
with that same four then she can stop
again right right don't add any more to
it because she's got too much already
right okay I agree that's what I mean
she can continue after she reaches 25
because 24 at 25 is all right yeah but
you know what you know what you know
what happens is though yeah is this
it stays at four and then you'll add
that to Jenny's on your back no no no no
but no but check it check it but then
she'll meet some guy and say your body
counts 20 these times she meets the guy
and she'll tell the guy it's full
right now she's on social media like the
thing is here the world's big you know I
mean like you could go [ __ ]
Manchester tomorrow meet some guy he's
not gonna know anything you know what I
mean you can't really like the world's
not big the world's big you meet a girl
in a bar tomorrow you don't know where
she's from what and she's from you don't
know you don't know any of our
background you've got you got no you've
got no mutual friends you've got no
mutual friends he's got 200 followers on
Instagram on on private do whatever I
mean like you're not gonna know her
background or her past you know I mean
she could tell you anything so in
reality nobody knows really yeah there's
hell Amanda a wife he's girls right now
if you really tell a big big lie the
worst person that you can live with is
yourself
because every time she goes out there
she will have a really good brain to
remember to lie all the time or even
that or she were telling herself all
right you were telling herself she would
ever end up lying and getting her so
caught up or she would end up telling us
I genuinely think like
okay if you're gonna be I think the
reason guys say that is because they're
not with girls that long anymore like
how many people have really I know I
think you said you an eight-year
relationship but that's not common right
like how many people are really together
long term 20 30 40 50 years if you're
with a girl for 50 years you think she
can keep that secret for 50 years you
don't think anything will come out you
don't think you'll run it I don't think
so especially you don't think her
friends might say something because her
friends are the ones that know okay so
so hold on one second yeah how much
woman yeah you know give men kids there
that's not theirs and men's years and
years later womans like seriously the
wicked like that's the thing that you
guys should watch it's called wicked
Matrix of women's I've give men kids
that's not their kids you're right
you're right you're absolutely
no no you're you're absolutely right
women can and do lie my point is that
the truth usually comes out eventually
because because the thing is like if you
if you hoe around for too long you can't
run from yourself you can't you are who
you are you are your habits so if you
have the habit of sleeping around for 10
15 years like you're gonna you're gonna
go back to the streets eventually your
friends your friends are gonna slip up
like the the crazy stories you told your
friends someone's gonna say something
like you don't think like girls talk and
eventually [ __ ] comes out go ahead the
thing is though they're Extremes in it
like if it goes you slept with like 15
guys or whatever she meets a guy she
really likes tells him oh my body counts
for right she's not gonna confess that
she's really 15 and her friends are not
going to beat up because it's not that
much of a big deal because like most
guys like when I was when I was dating
like I was going I was meeting girls
going out on dates every single girl I
met said I've not had sex in three
months oh that's the one
every single time
but it's the same thing and for me I was
like I've heard this so many times so I
know you're lying you know what I mean
but again
like if she adds 10 more to a body count
and by the time she's 25 26 meets the
one she could tell the guys 47. I ain't
gonna know I just I'm a big believer and
the truth comes out eventually and
someone's gonna say something where
you're like that doesn't add up or what
she said I think most girls or you might
meet someone that you know that that it
comes out that he slept I just think
eventually go ahead he had his hand up
before okay go ahead okay it doesn't it
doesn't thank you
no it doesn't always come out because um
I don't know if you like guys watch
stand-up uh comedy much like Chris Rock
said uh men tell the most lies men men
lie to most women tell the biggest lies
and um a guy you know a guy or girl can
go throughout a whole whole life you
know when like uh
you know you know the woman will be
she'll lie and say oh but you know the
baby's yours and um
so you guys can start crying
but I think in this day nature like
especially with social media and
everything yeah like it's harder in it
like I don't think you could get away
with as much nowadays especially
nowadays yeah girls want to be posted
like it's a big thing for a girl like so
whatever you ain't said once you get
posted especially if you're like
nowadays everyone's bait like a lot of
people are big okay so nowadays you get
posted you go out you got friends
everyone's connected by what four or
five years
nowadays you might not find out about
every one of the body count but you will
find out about enough where it's like
yeah yeah all right you get a chance you
get a gist you post a new girl enough
and then like you can tell from the
people that pop up you know um
girls have a digital stuff so I mean
you'll see yeah you'll see if she was at
the clubs every weekend five years ago I
mean you're gonna get a couple bodies
again for five years
for all of us yes yeah if if you tell
the guy your body count and he has an
issue with it does does that give you
the ick I like it does cause why do you
care like also if you ask them because I
guarantee you because I've talked to
people about body accounts before at the
age of 18 now there's so many guys that
is double what mine is like I think I
thought yeah I don't think it should
matter because the people that get the
most are the ones that trust they have
so many more than you okay no no guys
guys what do you think Paul no I I think
that it matters it absolutely matters
and every data you look at the more the
more guys you sleep with the more likely
you are to be divorced really yeah and
okay if you and there's a couple
different studies so the numbers vary a
little bit but one there's one study
where if you slept if you're a virgin
when you get married you have an 80
chance of a happy marriage in 10 years
80 and you know what it drops to After
Five Guys which most men pray for
nowadays 25 chance of being happily
married after 10 years so and then
people will you know there's other
studies that it's fifty percent forty
percent thirty percent of whatever it is
but the most happy tend to be the
virgins who's trying to marry a virgin
though really interesting yeah that's
long aren't just alone
give me a version they've got no
experience yeah that's why I'm a teacher
that's a few damage
I know we have to go to the extremes to
like to prove the point because
historically men
had to ensure paternity so they had to
know am I am I passing on resources to a
kid that's mine because historically we
didn't have paternity tests we didn't
have DNA tests so the only way they
could decipher that is is this woman
pure how does she act how is she modest
et cetera et cetera et cetera but you
know going back to it I I really don't
think that you can hide it for you can
only hide it for so I'm surprised how
many men are still not doing DNA tests
you know what I'm saying there's a lot
of men are not doing them because you
know a man's told us these kids
I'm sorry you see the things you're not
me too you see the things that Jamaican
guy said this he said listen any man
could have a kid you don't need to breed
a girl because a woman get pregnant and
tell you the kids is yours you don't
know if the kids did the woman said he's
serious and you're like yeah man you
take the kid you move on again that's
what I'm saying you don't have the kids
are we talking about Jamaican men okay
you can't talk about yourself let me
call you not because we [ __ ] you down
you gave it to us because my dad is
Jamaican and I'm around a lot of
Jamaican men and I know a lot of
Jamaican men who have a bag of Pitney
yeah
you know I might be a sailor I know what
you mean I know a [ __ ] yeah Twitter
you're getting on to me oh you should
have kids yeah I said what man I got
this much kids you had a pair of twins
twins swab them wasn't his but there was
this for a minute I see let's bring moms
back into this let's bring moms back
into this this is where moms come in
handy okay more often than not your mom
would be the first one that's the DNA
tested you know so your mom will tell
you I don't know about it I don't know
about that one you know you see the one
that you don't want to claim your mom
will tell you listen that one's one of
yours yeah trust me your mom's a DNA
test me yeah especially in the Jamaican
Community
your mom will tell you your mama told
you before you know before your girl
knows your mama said that one's Courier
actually I have a question for the guys
all right you're trying to wipe a girl
what's the what's the best amount of
bodies
none serious to be honest I don't care
in an Ideal World
I personally not the award virgin but
that's virgin okay okay that's fine what
about you you said you didn't want a
virgin so I'm just curious what's the
what's the perfect amount of guys who
have slept with your wife there's not a
perfect amount no there if it's not zero
what is it yeah what is it bro I'm just
you might said you did what a virgin so
well you know the reason why I said I
don't like the thing is yeah bro have
you been with a virgin yeah I have how
how was the brain wonderful how was the
brain it's wonderful the brain wonderful
you see my ego knowing that okay so
knowing that you've never been on your
knees before my ego is yo if the brain
if the brain was fantastic yeah that
means she's been giving birth
[Music]
because my ego is going through the roof
knowing that it doesn't mean go on your
knees before and I'm directing you it's
a wonderful it's such a piece of mind I
want to go back to this how many
I don't to be honest doesn't matter to
me no so because because you never truly
know that's how I feel oh no no it has
to be it has to be less than 15. less
than six so so good numbers is ten under
15. so three or ten yeah 10 to 15. so
you want 10 guys to have screwed your
wife
that's a lot of possibilities you know
yeah right but the reality is yeah
that's the most most women you know I
understand I understand yeah but you see
what I'm asking though I understand I
prefer ten over zero no obviously okay
so five over zero you rather have five
guys have screwed your wife
I don't know about the thing is when you
structured a question like that they do
now when you structured a question like
that obviously like you would want that
one woman to only be with you that's it
but it's not realistic I understand and
if you do get that the reality is the
more times that they're not the
experience is going to be [ __ ] because
she doesn't know for the first couple
times but if you're you know a general
teacher
everyone learn somehow even these girls
just aliens abducted them and taught
them how to do this he's got patience to
be teaching now
if you're gonna be married do you have
you here running back and she folds over
if you're gonna be married you have a
long time to teach her
you have years if you find a virgin
bring her to me our teacher yeah
and it was like it was just the
experience I was thinking to myself
what's the point I might as well just
carry on seeing my other teams because
because the beat was so dead I have his
oil see what you're saying on me my
bread chips are folding up
can I just ask how many women will have
a virgin out there
the women on the surface how many of
these look whatever virgin a virgin guy
or a virgin girl it's up to you I don't
know what your preferences come on now
come on
to be honest Auntie do you know what I
would you know virgin girl that's it um
I'd have a virgin birth to be honest but
I feel like yeah I have a veg in both
because I do like both myself okay
um okay however
you said that first I want to be so
shocked okay then um but I'll be willing
to say I wouldn't jump for joy about it
at first if that makes sense like I
won't be like right I wouldn't shave my
money and be like right I'm getting it
in tonight because I know I'm gonna say
if you had a non-virgin and a virgin you
would take the
I feel like the idea is better than the
experience like because it's because
it's basically it's what you're telling
yourself like you're you're there and
you're like yes I'm the only person
that's been in here but the experience
that's great she said she wouldn't have
a virgin I'm curious
um what was the issue with the girl that
was a virgin you said the sex was bad
yeah and if you just Potter what if you
like taught her something I didn't have
time for that you didn't have time
okay so you're having the virgins like
having a picnic you've got lately
[Music]
but it was just more like the idea of it
wasn't as good as the experience
um
too much is that what it is did it go
back after that Turtle what about what
about you guys would you date an origin
or a virgin guy you know what I wouldn't
be like no I wouldn't but I would prefer
a more experienced man yes okay what
about you
that's a tough question because I'm not
trying to have sex before marriage you
know they're not even just I know yeah
after like the last one I really deeply
I want to get closer with Jesus on that
so
yeah it's gonna be one of these Born
Again virgins
[Music]
have to be hers no no I didn't say they
have to be hoes
the reality out there is like yeah you
know just because the reality is like
that doesn't mean there's nothing to do
percentage
why you always go back to a whole team
do you want to be a [ __ ] or something
no I'm trying he never said that though
you had to shoot him in the
heading to say none of that I hear what
my woman said clearly he didn't say no
no no he said but you want to be an
actress and I said I don't have to and
he said he said you want to be an
actress he said it does noches is a
[ __ ]
so in this consistently situation of
course he meant that it means what did
you mean what did you mean the same like
it's just reality we're human beings
right like
opportunity will present itself in
different ways oh sorry opportunity will
present itself in a different way you
know like it's not you know it's not
going to be a dick on a plate like
they're just saying oh yeah it eat me
like it's opportunity comes in different
ways
[Laughter]
can I ask you why why it is fair to go
back to church when you're not having
sex because is it religious thing or is
it just that you feel safer in church
having no sex that you feel that
nobody's going to have sex with you in
church no that's not you know that's the
bad thing is the first person I've had
sex with wasn't sure like I mean I was
about to say though that's not the
reason oh sorry that's not the reason
why I just
there's a point in my life where I sat
there and I really duped what type of
person do I want to be and I wanna and I
realized I want to get close to God it's
not even about the church I don't like
the church I go to I can't lie but it's
about me and I personally want to go
close to God
so you think you need to go to a church
okay
yes Cindy I think
and everyone else but personally for me
that's an understanding don't listen to
them heathens I'm with you girl yeah so
I have a question though because this is
a common complaint that I hear from guys
it's it's kind of like the born-again
Virgin thing where it's like a guy that
is gonna wait for a girl that's slept
with other men for marriage like he's
kind of a simp and that's why guys are
leaving the church because they thought
they were going to get virgins and they
get girls that have slept with multiple
men the women are going to be awesome
sometimes
because you know something like that
you know what right A lot of people say
the women right but a lot of men go to
church just for sakes no you're right
you're right but thanks when they have
sex with the women they just leave them
no so you never say pictures but it's
hard it's hard because like I agree with
you like I don't I don't think people
should sleep around right like I'm with
you but like at the same time it's like
I think a lot of times the church leaves
women single and you see that because I
walk into any church at 70 to 80 women
they're usually single and and the thing
is I meet a lot of girls that are
celibate you know and to guys it just
sounds like nonsense it's like where
where was this celibacy when you're
you're a [ __ ] chat or Tyrone or
whoever it was
my mind
I understand
and it's a little more like I think the
younger girls are a little bit more
genuine because they're they're younger
when they do a lot of girls get there at
like 29 to 30 with a kid and they're
like yeah I'm gonna wait again and the
guys are like [ __ ] that yeah that makes
no sense but and then this might be at a
smaller scale but it's like like a lot
of times I I do think the church leaves
women single because they tell them to
be celibate again but it's a bad deal
for men because they have to wait for a
girl to be like to get her to be married
but at the same time she gets all the
commitments I don't believe that go
ahead no no she's right she's right
still no she's not because nobody forces
the women to go to sleep no no no no no
no no no they go to church as a
backslider Auntie Jenny they go to
church Auntie Jenny let me ask you Jenny
speak then they go to church right the
women go to church thinking that they
can hide in the church and they can't
hide in the church they're only fooling
themselves because all they do some of
their women is go there to give their
[ __ ] a rest you understand I'm not
gonna say like it is so when they're
saying about Moon again Christians it's
not it's not now born again energy they
just go there to take the heat off their
families and that's when they go to give
their family a rest I
can say Auntie Jenny you still want to
say no because some of them
I'm gonna say that somebody don't go to
church but at the end of the day they
will go out there and sleep with a whole
heap of man
and then go when their fan is too hot
and then go say you know what I'm gonna
chill out in church and wait for a man
to come and that's what it is a church
is not a resting place for a hot Fanny
do you know what I mean that is not what
it's there for if you decide and
honestly because I'm religious if you
decide that you had enough and you want
to go there but don't go when it when
people go to church right after having a
relationship they think they can go
there and be born again no they're not
born again because you're really born
again ain't no Boone again you still
have to remember all the men that you've
had and you start to deal with all the
men that you've had and you have to be
honest with the men that you're gonna
have or the future husband so don't go
to church and think that you can hide
away all the heads that you've had and
all the men that you fight because you
can't hide it until you're fooling
yourself but even even if the girls are
honest in the church yeah they go to the
men and they say hey this is what I'm
selling I'm a used Honda Civic here this
is I'm selling myself for new BMW prices
and the men are like oh uh why would why
would I do that when I could get another
used Honda Civic do you know well the
men need to go and get the other Honda
Civic because what the women fail to
realize is that there's a name for women
like that in church is it monarch and
there's women in there's what they feel
to realize is that when all these women
run to church right to get away from it
they don't realize that there's some
women in the Bible that never have a man
that always been in church that will
never ever ever have a man and 90 of
their women are gonna it's like a
religious leftover woman right right you
know I mean that's what they're going to
end up with I know but that's what I'm
saying like a lot of times when the
church will encourage women to wait till
they're married after they've had
they're not virgins anymore I think it
leads to worse outcomes because because
again it's everywhere Auntie I'm telling
you I've had these conversations with
people in Christian churches Catholic
Church like it's across the board walk
into any church in the west it's 70 to
80 women and and this is why because
from a reproductive like mating strategy
it gives all the benefits to women and
and all of the responsibility on the men
I go to church and I'm not hypocrite I
go to church regular and I'm taking
nothing I'm taking nothing because I
know as soon as I come out of church I'm
going to have sex
Auntie Jenner you gotta realize yeah
woman's go to church here as what you
said to go rest the minji yeah but what
it's it's like when you release it I'm
gonna use your example it's like when
you lose a family member you turn to
religion for comfort in it these women
go turn to the pastor for comfort and
the pastor start talking and
brainwashing them to me church is a big
brain or [ __ ] I don't need to go to
church to praise my God in it exactly so
they're getting brainwashing church I
know you said leftover that's why she
just said leftover oh wait no someone's
gonna come and get him I don't want you
you're a black dog Bentley from
the thing is right is that I find that
when the women want to go and find a man
right they will go all around the world
right they will go on holiday they would
look here and they would look there and
then when it comes to finding a man in
church they stick to the one church now
imagine
she said I go to a church and I don't
like it but I'm gonna where the hell are
you going to the church that you don't
like there's obviously no meaning that
you like the whole world is your oyster
I'm sure that when you're out there
looking man you look at them and the
whole world so if you want to find a man
in it you've got the whole world of
church she's like go to a Jamaican
Church you're going to find the man
that's good you know
what I said go to we'll send you a
chance why are you gonna stay in one
church when that church might not be
right for you well you're saying there's
multiple strip clubs
go to all of them and test it out
I think they go to church or whatever
religious practice it is with the right
intention yeah they go there because
whatever they've been doing outside
hasn't been working yet and they want to
get closer to God even in within a
relationship marriage they want to do it
the right way yeah like the religious
way whatever that boom but I feel like
with women here with that kind of
comfortability now and familiarity with
the men what you're now constantly
around in church these men are still
still you know active there you go and I
feel like the familiarity now that
they've now built with these men and
this comfort and the safety they feel
around the Christian Brothers if it's a
Christian Church what happens now is
after a while you slip into the same
cycle but now it's just within a church
Community because not just within the
church you build like you join the group
chat now you're going out socially with
General I mean different churches
different guys and now with that
familiarity it becomes easier for what
me now to lie down and then what happens
you end up getting run how you got
around to the majority and it runs you
in the streets you'll end up getting run
to in church within the church and when
I say run to you it don't have to be
nothing mad like 20 man it could be
three or four okay but but that 304 is
detrimental because it's within the same
community so now what you're doing is
your proper limit in your charts of
getting it that's why what Paul said in
the end the percentage is very high
which don't end up with the ring because
within your church Community you know
Marlon Aaron and John has run through it
so you're thinking like no that's mad
and you gotta go Church what with the
wife you know what Marlon Jenner and
Aaron Ranchi like the point the point is
like I don't think telling women to wait
after they've had sex produces good
outcomes and I see this because I see
there's so many celibate girls in the
church and the ones I believe that like
actually are celibate it's like they're
still single and they're so simple
because again they're selling a used
Honda Civic for new prices how come
we're not talking about the men you see
my best friends right because because
the problem is men and women are
different and women don't care if a guy
slept with a lot of people but we just
okay like this is kind of a need to be
right and I think on an innate level you
know that it's true because we just
talked to the girls on the couch just in
this conversation the men said by and
large they tended to want virgins but we
tended to want men that have slept with
other women and it's just true and it's
not it's not fun like it's not a fun
part of being a woman but it just it is
what it is like the women have
consequences for that stuff men get more
chicks who's lining up to for Drake and
saying oh did he sleep with too many
girls no ingenuously the Britney Runner
they're running from yeah
to have that man for a woman to get wife
by a man that the majority of women want
it's like a trophy like he chose me
in the majority like you you wanted the
popular kid that majority of the girl is
popular because majority of the girls
because that's why they have all this
funny trauma and then they go to church
trying to relieve it Jeremy because I
gotta speak because I got a friend and
she's been in the church for like I
don't know about 30 years and she ain't
got no man and you know what she never
went to church looking for no man so she
don't expect to go because she never
went to church with funny trauma do you
know what I mean so she always went to
church she said if a man that was a man
if a man comes along fine I never it's a
eunuch that's the word and if a man
doesn't come along I said you're a unit
he goes why are you putting it on that
me I've still got time to find the man I
said this one give up my name you're
eunuch you know what I mean some women
go to church and they're going to church
thinking that yeah all women are
supposed to find men in church no some
of the women are supposed to be single
in church for 30 40 years unless you do
your research and so when you go to
don't go to church trying to get cancer
for yourself
but they say to be fruitful and multiply
you don't you don't think it's going a
little bit against God to not get with a
man if you ever saw if you're over 30
years old for no bag it seemed like
having a lifter
you know you just said you knock here
that's used for a term that older woman
that has never kidding it and she can't
have a kid no more so she it's like it's
like the term they use when a woman hit
the menopause
yeah
I thought that was um someone that
didn't have a dick no yeah
you understand what I'm saying though
right yeah so it's like it's like you
should be able to go to church they
should be able to go to church and free
it up
a lot of times I think the church leaves
women single because they encourage them
to wait till they're married after
they've had sex and what and what kind
of guy is going to do that when he knows
you banged the three dudes down the
street
right because I don't see no one
dragging the women into church
I don't see no one so the church don't
turn around and say to women oh come
here we're gonna find the man for you
it's the women with their funny trauma
that decide to go to church so the
church don't make them stay there if
they will get cancer for their family
trauma half of them women if they got
counseling before they were interjected
but yeah they're still screwing around
because they get counseling about the
one guy that broke their heart and then
they will move on they wouldn't be in
church so I don't I won't say blame the
church because at the end of the day
nobody gets forces into church they go
there they're all free will they go
there because they think of themselves
oh all these men outside are treating me
bad I'm gonna come in and find some
stupid Christian guy that's gonna take
me as I am because you don't care about
body care you know what those are the
eunuchs of the future those are the
leftover women
and I agree with you I'm just saying
like like this stuff to men it kind of
reports and this is just feedback I've
gotten because I I kind of had the same
view as you before I just started
listening to guys talk more and it's
like from the men's point of view it's
like you're encouraging these girls to
wait again but what do we get out of it
we don't get a virgin bride why would we
do that and so and so stuff like that
makes men want to not go to church I use
a church leader you want to ask them and
how many how many of them guys go into
church and [ __ ] the girls and come back
out without evidence a little man go to
church
right right
now
I actually I have a whole Theory
I have okay I have a whole theory that
like the church is actually like a
homemaker and like it's actually like a
a breeding ground for hoes and I'll tell
you what I'll tell you why okay because
it's like what they'll do is they'll
have these chastities and I remember
being in high school because I've always
been me you know I've always kind of
like thought the way I do but I was just
like a young Pearl in high school and we
had this Chastity speaker and I was
thinking like basically she went up and
she said I got ran through but then I
found God you know praise God and then
the husband was like and then the
husband was like oh yeah and I I found
her after this and like I was a virgin
and I waited and she and it's oh and I
realized I was like it's always the
women who didn't wait and I'm like oh
it's like they're kind of marketing you
can be a hoe and then find a husband
like it's like a marketing like I don't
think they mean to but I'm like oh it's
like that's what they're marketing to
young women and I remember like wanting
to like ask this question but Catholic
School couldn't handle but you're saying
that so and so then and so then it's
like on top of that the pastors have
this reputation for screwing the
congregation right that's like that's
like yeah that's like that's that's a
common thing I guess
it wasn't it was I've heard it I've
heard it I've heard it here I've heard
it in both places but and I'm like why
is there The Stereotype they must do it
a lot right Justin Bieber's like priest
or whatever Pastor came out and I'm like
no wonder they preach forgiveness
because he wants to screw all the hoes
and so what he's saying is he's saying
all of you guys can wait I'm gonna screw
them and add to the bodies
and then you guys can all marry him
after I'm done and that's that's my kind
of preacher and that's why I have this
theory that like a church is really like
that's why that's why the guys will
because the guys will all tell me the
girls are worse in the church and I'm
like why would they be worse because
they basically Market that you can be a
hoe forever and then get a husband at
the end and so then all the hoes go she
said it's a whole show so it's a whole
show yeah yeah yeah it's a whole show
I want to ask everybody have you ever
seen how the women I'm gonna say black
queen because what happened that just
that good
um
am I lying I literally I don't get
involved enough I love woman I ever see
the black woman go to church right how
she dresses what how much cleavage she
shows what how much heals
how the makeup
how she can walk up and wine better
insurance and as she was in a rave I'm
not gonna lie watch out I'll drive past
a church going forward you see them
Sunday morning
it's Sunday morning
she just call you first no but hey what
I'm saying Sunday morning Sunday morning
I heard it but Sunday morning you're
going football you still got sleep in
your eyes
a herd of of beautiful women
must have come back from Brixton must
not go into Brixton from the night
before to get the men and nine times out
of ten those women in church get run
through by the men that are visiting
because they got a habit and the mothers
and the mother and the mothers and the
mothers don't forget the mothers you
know because the mothers yeah will
encourage them to look your best your
Sunday Best in other words
imagine if the pastors came forward okay
imagine if they said okay like because
they're like they'll say they'll say you
can be saved right like the like the
hoes they'll be like hoes come to church
maybe they don't say it like that so
they basically say hoes come to church
because you can be forgiven for
everything imagine if they said men
don't accept that don't you like wait
for the next round of women leave them
right they will what
no you're right you're right that's why
like that's why I've got there aren't a
lot of guys in general walk into any
church at 70 to 80 women but just
imagine if they flipped it and they said
don't accept that for like the same way
they'll tell men and I can't I'm trying
to articulate this right but the same
way they'll tell women like your husband
should be this this this he should be
equally yoked to man of God blah blah
blah blah blah but it's like they don't
say to the men don't date these ran
through girls don't do it you don't
deserve that you deserve better you
should date this this and this like it's
always what the women should expect from
a husband you know what because the men
that go to church have less bloody count
than the women that go to church yeah I
know but no but I think that's why
though because the men that actually
understand female nature they think this
is nonsense it's all the symptoms
you know what we call these women a
doors and we don't know what to do so
you know we've got to make some weight
like men they're really nice they're
Christians that you take them because
nobody else outside church is going to
want them so they might as well take the
ones no I I think they want to keep the
women single in the church because they
have to make money off of them like each
each girl gives how much a week and like
that's that's the thing and it's kind of
like it's weird because they ask for
donations but when there's more single
homeless women over the age of like
that's the fastest growing homeless
population single women and so if
they're if they're giving like a hundred
bucks a week let's say that's 400 a
month times that by a year that that's a
retirement account go ahead similar I
don't want to say it similar to a club
environment the more attractive women
you attracted
willing with the hand open mental tables
is good it's got more money right so the
men are gonna come and spend their money
most of the charity books
when you're young yeah it's like you're
not necessarily just going to your local
church you're going to the popular
church the church that's popping yeah
that's got that young good looking
environment that's the one you're going
and you're going there in your best
you're waking up early Sunday morning in
your drip like what yo
I remember being in and I've always been
a Miss I've always had these thoughts
but I remember being like younger and
they would say make a list of the things
you want in your future husband and I'm
like why don't they say that to the men
make a list of what you want in your
future wife but the problem is none of
the girls in the congregation can meet
that hmm
so basically all these women just go
into church to find the good guys
because they're tired of all the bad
boys I think I think that's a that's
what's like the common response but a
lot of times
and this is
from from guys that it's 28 29 30 right
when time's running out is when they
tend to go to church and if they do get
to church young they leave right when
they get to college and so it's like but
that's your church
I'm not talking about my church I'm
talking about General feedback I
wouldn't even say I'm crazy religious
but I'm saying that's General feedback
I've just gotten from men like their exp
like different churches same experience
wow those are my churches because I've
seen so many churches with young people
I don't know I didn't see the evidence
who said their church at night
there's somebody someone from your
church a girl is busting up with a man
right now from your church because human
beings
she listen did you say they're going to
church to get husband and all that
buttocks
yeah that's not the reason
you could do that for your yard you
could do that
on the topic of going to church and
making it all about like relationships
and stuff I when I went to church I
recently found God properly and started
going church and stuff and it had
nothing to do with no man no
relationship it was because I was
dealing with my own internal traumas and
God was my backbone God was my safe
place so I wanted to explore what type
of trauma was it was it the no ft no it
wasn't I don't know what that is uh
funny tumor yeah see auntie look what
you're done now no no not the Ft no ft
no comments
you see that's what I'm telling you guys
got it to see comfort you know no but we
got to see Christ
my last point and then I stopped is that
I feel like for me it's because I've had
it emotional trauma I was learning more
about God at home and I wanted to go to
church more because I wanted to learn
more from people who have spent years
studying it preaching it mastering it
that sort of stuff so my point is I'm
just saying it ain't always about this
sexualization or of women going to
church have a back of bad relationships
because not not every woman is doing
that you might you might not say it it's
not all women I I agree with you it's
just funny when women always seem to
come after a whole phase that's just
what I've heard from the men it's just
it's just interesting how right after
the whole phase now you're here
fascinating I went to church when I when
I was younger and my dad's made me go
and I went and I had a good time and
then as I got older I kind of dropped it
out and I went for a time in my life in
2013 and
um I feel like a lot of people speak to
God when their balls deep in the ship or
when they when they need a bit of
guidance or need a bit of help not like
oh God you know I'm doing good and XYZ I
feel like back then I looked so good to
help me in a situation and God's told me
that the outcome that I wanted to happen
ain't gonna happen and guess what it
never happened good was right and from
then I said you know what there was
someone up there I'm not crazy so I am a
Christian and from a young age my
stepdad wanted me my dad wanted me to be
a Christian but I feel like I find that
space Within Myself and I don't go
church but I'm still a Christian and I
didn't go to church fan dick I was like
10 or 10 you know what I mean
last time you had sex the last time I
had sex about what seven weeks ago oh my
word what about you today has any of the
women had sex
several weeks ago a couple weeks or
something no but it's not by choice
trust me
it's not it's not it's not no that is by
a choice it's by choice so I didn't mean
it went by choice but it's not like I'm
happy about it but I also it's like a
you gotta think bigger than the
temptation of the day I'm not gonna lie
I'll be so honest with you yeah I'll be
honest I'm saying it's all respect I
don't care you don't believe me you [ __ ]
yesterday
but it's like in my mind I'm thinking
about the bigger picture yeah that's
that's a bit of self-consciousness
what is the bigger picture
okay so for me I feel like the bigger
picture is if I don't open up my legs I
feel like it's a better Gateway for a
guy to take me serious more so I feel
like
I don't wanna the reason why I'm not
having sex right now is because I feel
like the next guy I wanna I don't want
to have sex with a guy and it just be
that see you in a veteran period where
you're you're trying to identify that
guy to open sesame's for no no I just
feel like for me I want to I want it to
be more deeper I want it to go down the
relationship exactly you haven't got
someone that you think cool I don't want
a relationships
I had that I did have that more for
yourself and then I was like now yeah
let's ask the guys girls what what
should girls do
how long should how long would you wait
for a girl before you're you're saying
no Seven Days
Seven Days
seven days what about you I can only
speak for myself personally every girl
I've had sex with I've never waited more
than five or six days anyway hey you see
a big dog you know so yeah
I don't know any difference so it's hard
to answer that question okay five how
long would you wait
only the five was like between five and
six days because that's all I've ever
done come see this horny [ __ ]
what if she was she seemed wifey how
long would you give her even in neck
that's what I'm saying that's that's got
a week do you want to be married at some
point
possibly possible
how long would you wait if I'm looking
at her like worthy potential yeah I want
her to at least wait two weeks two weeks
okay and then how long how long is too
long
a month
okay now seriously I'm sticking to my
seven days
seven days are balanced okay see I'll be
honest yeah
see me I'll I'm willing like it's a bit
of a I'm willing to wait longer for you
to respect your thing if I feel like
it's genuine that you're trying to
figure me out if I'm you're trying to
actually see assess me as a is he like a
proper guy or whatnot if I feel like
you're just
you're like you're not actually trying
to figure me out you're just trying to
prove a point to yourself that you can
wait there's the Egypt you're not gonna
hear from you again but in general it
doesn't matter what like no matter what
the man them say like they've said two
weeks seven days what not really and
truly like I could wait for you I could
wait two months because I feel like
whatever whatever but try not demand
them are beating there's Nets get a lot
of free now
so it's just where you can do that
approach but you have to also know the
consequences more than likely the man in
my beat like you you're he's been
reviewed now you ain't got no I might
have got to kiss and rub up and that's
it and then what he's at the door all
right cool when Shelly Ann's down the
road
today
okay Auntie what are you saying from
your perspective how long should women
wait if they're not I just want to ask
it another way let me change it for you
I you ask the man I want to ask the
ladies is that right can I do that yeah
go ahead I want to ask the ladies from a
time what's the longest time you spent
from seeing a guy you liked to sleeping
with the guy and was he the one what's
the longest I'm here seven days I want
to hear from the women what's the
longest you went from meeting a guy he
said I like him to actually sleeping
with him what's the longest Gap
start anyway
for me the longest ever would be um my
my ex partner my baby dad that I was
doing for eight years because we lost
our journey to each other so obviously
yeah there was over a year oh yeah from
the time you saw it imagine two so when
I lost my virginity to him he lost his
so what about by the time you saw him
that's the longest Gap you've ever had
no not from the time I saw him because
we established we liked each other after
we met each other but from the time that
we realized that we that we've been up
that we we're for each other yeah there
was no pressure on sex because he never
so because he never had sex Neva so he
didn't put pressure on me because he was
both virgins so it that time was right
for us so was he the one no he wasn't
okay
so and the next lady please the next
lady so I
um waited three months for a guy I
really liked because I thought the whole
mind the whole theory of you know keep
it close you know I mean anyway I got
played and I took a l because that's
what I said yeah I mean I did take it
out with that one simply because it was
one of them I I I yeah I took a loss
basically he played me basically and I
was like played yourself no I didn't
oh okay okay all right I'll be fair then
but no yeah I I don't feel like I played
myself I just feel because I do because
you like to I do feel like the the
majority not every guy but I do feel
like the majority of guys have the same
mindset of you as if you [ __ ] too quick
so let me say something you waited three
months yeah you made the guy you like
wait three months so you see in
previously
previously yeah I bet there's guys that
you ain't even like that much that you
probably beat within weeks like a week
because you don't like them like that no
but obviously for you look I hear what
you are saying but you see for men
if a guy if a guy takes you on a first
date and it's it's the nicest first date
you've ever been on like you you can all
think of one where he just went above
and beyond for you and you knew he liked
you a lot and and to guys it's like the
quicker you sleep with them it's the
more you like them really yeah so what
do they say those things though when
like like I'm not saying all guys again
but why do they say that oh man [ __ ]
on the first night she's a jazz or like
they'd be like yeah yeah because because
this is and this is this is why it's
like a double-edged sword because they
they want they want you to be a hoe just
for them yeah
it's kind of like it's kind of like you
want a guy that treats you better than
he treated all these others like you
know what like if
like if same way
yeah
it's like she said no to all of them but
she let me hit it but it's like it's a
different thing than when yeah
it's put them off before like they think
because because he thinks that's some
immature it's because it's because she
won't be dead it's because
he thinks you're doing it with everyone
and so that's why I said it's there's no
winning there's no secret I think if
there is a secret formula on how how to
get what you want out of a relationship
like everyone would buy it there's no
winning secret but I'm saying like that
the reason that it puts them off is
because they think you're doing it with
everyone and women lie so much like how
how the hell are they supposed to know
if if when I when I was dating if I met
a girl and she put out on the first date
I'm thinking she's doing that to every
single man she's going on a date with
you know what I mean so and I'm not
going to believe anything she says if a
girl puts out on a first date and says
her body counts five I'm like you're
late what she put out and then you heard
from your friend that he she turned him
down would that change it or no I'm just
curious no because she probably turned
she could have just said yes to Bear
oven
okay fair enough go ahead
and it was mum's when she first met I'm
not gonna ask this young lady I don't
want to ask because I don't want to know
I don't want to know this is not for you
I'm not asking you nothing so just
listen right I don't want to hear so
what it is no the same question that I
was saying but now now you said you met
him when you was a virgin you saying you
put out after how many years nobody's
sure about the one
I met my partner
and we were friends hanging out with
each other with a group of friends
for over two years well I got to know
him oh
no he didn't see me like that we were
friends no he was friends he was friends
though and that's different I liked him
he liked me I was hanging out with a
loaded guys so we became friends and
then when we hit it off when we started
sleeping together nobody else got in
between how long did it take though
young ladies right is that when they
hang out with women they don't find that
[ __ ] from women you understand I hang
out with men so and then their men work
so I didn't care who he been over
because it wasn't me I see you know I've
been best friends with men and seen them
got with girls and sleep with girls and
I'm like watch out for that girl you
know what I mean because I'm like the
friend the proper with the guys so when
you get to when you got to know me and
realized that you know what she's all
right then when it comes to having sex I
know what men are like you're asking me
I'm gonna say yes because you know that
if you've got a woman that got of a
group of friends a group of male friends
nobody's going to approach you but
there's one guy that would approach it
and say you know what and I liked him so
I said well why not he goes well I'm
gonna I'm gonna say no come on give me
two years I've been watching you are you
watching am I gonna say no so you said
Auntie but the difference like it's a
generational thing right because because
no because because this is the
generational thing like before if if a
guy if a girl was turning guys down on
the first date and making him wait guys
knew that like she wasn't sleeping
around because she usually wasn't but
the problem is now guys are putting in
all this effort and waiting for a girl
and they find out she screwed everyone
else before and so but in your days like
women I would assume women weren't as
like sleeping around right but like he
said if I if I knew that I wasn't going
to sleep with him he's gonna go and
sleep with other people I don't mind
because it's not me I'm aware of it how
you said you know he might take me out
on a date drop me off to my doorstep I'm
gonna screw someone these things I don't
care about that because I know that you
dropped me home we had a nice time go
and get your rock so you don't feel like
you got played but no she's not got
played she sorry so I don't want to say
she but she felt yeah no because she was
that yeah
it's different though because my mom was
sitting in a friend zone for two years
so you weren't even dating like that but
no she was trying to date night to know
him first Auntie let me ask you one
question you said meantime he was
getting to know me he was smashing you
yeah yeah you said you said meantime he
was getting to know him you you you were
smashing someone else here I'm sorry
various people so I apologize for this
year I really do yeah yeah go for it
well you smashing it
yeah yeah thank you thank you not during
that time
for two years
I see the difference is Right some
people right when they have trauma they
run to church with their ft do you know
what I mean and some people right when
they have trauma they hang out with
their male friends and watch and learn
from their male friends so when I have
like ft trauma I hang around with my
male friends you know what I mean and
share it goes and learn from them how
they operate
that's who gives me trauma my mouth
friends are you sleeping with your male
friends no I'm not and why are they
giving you trauma because I'm close with
them
I'm in their private
I'm in that private service so therefore
I can see what my friends are doing
behind the scenes and they're posting
this to go on Tuesday and then let's go
on Wednesday and then the two girls with
their penalty off on a Thursday I can
see how they're operating and what
they're doing because I'm close enough
with them for them to tell me I just
bust out a two goal last night and then
our best friend was sucking on a cookie
the next day I'm close enough to to be
able to understand that so that's what
gives me trauma I'm thinking if you're
like that I know the next man's like
that but it's not always the way but it
is so you got cocky trauma then
yeah
you see what's making me upset you and I
swear to God [ __ ] need to stop do this
I'll beg you up please stop baiting your
team up this is why cheating this is why
[ __ ] are messing up a game I'm getting
caught because [ __ ] are doing stupid
[ __ ] no one never do not no one would
never know nothing I swear to God no one
will never know I hear what she said
tell me who you sit with um I'm a girl
in your mouth no but outside of
friendship outside the Friendship zones
there's girls with Brothers in it
there's girls who predominantly men in
their family so well it is though you
just gotta see it for what it is so you
can't just take the trauma the Badness
the negativity out of the situation you
gonna also see in them instances okay
what did she do wrong for why did you
treat her like that because also if you
watch your friends carefully they'll be
one what they're treating good I
guarantee you that they'll be one what
they're spending on they'll be one what
they might even be calling you and
saying yo all right what's your name
Katrina Katrina Katrina there'll be one
I feel like I've met you before but
there'll be one that they're leaving
they'll be one that they'll even cool
you and say like yo all right babe like
that not baby because your friend but
you know that I I'm taking her right now
what do you think that give me a
suggestion or there'll be one but the
rest so you would just want to know okay
maybe ask questions how do I get to be
that one you see what I'm trying to say
no I feel like as a male I feel like I
feel like if you want to do something
you're going to do it if you don't want
to do something she's just not gonna no
no but I'm saying about your perspective
of what you're seeing so you say you got
Trauma from seeing your friends deal
with girls because down on the opposite
there's always one that there might be
nine that they treat in math but
there'll be one that they're treating
Goods but the thing is so you just gotta
take that out the majority of men aren't
even having or the majority of men don't
get laid like that it's hard for men to
get laid again one one out of every
three guys isn't having sex in your age
group I hope that's mine yeah what uh
you can okay you can even look at dating
app statistics what that's that's where
women are the most honest what
percentage of the time do women swipe
right at high 20 it's not that high
though it's like five
and women women what percent of guys do
you think are over six foot
the guy I'm talking to is at five foot
eight I'm living okay I understand it's
not that's what this is just an example
what percent of guys do you think are
over six foot like just generally
generally
um maybe like 30 business totally like
20 in it it's 15. really 15 so a lot of
times girls want a guy that's six four
what percent of men and even and even
and even and even if if maybe he's short
he has a good face right yeah
what percent of guys are have a really
symmetrical face if you want them to be
tall good looking make money that's
that's all that they can't have it all
they can't have it all but I'm saying
like if you want to sleep with a guy I
promise to God other girls want to sleep
with him like even the guys that girl
say he's medium ugly no even even the
girl the the guys that girls call medium
ugly he's not medium ugly that's just
your level it's just like oh yeah I know
my men like cut out my steak medium and
Rich I mean
[Laughter]
not a chubby chaser but I am a chubby
chaser I feel like if it's too much skin
and bone it's not for me but I feel like
if it's got a little bit of chub not too
muscle you know just liquid juice
are you doing that you know he's five
foot eight you know he's got a bit of
bells yeah a dad but that's it I love
that so if you do like the dad bud
because you're attracted to it or
because
are you are you attracted to the dad
like the fat or are you attractive are
you or are you you gotta let me finish
the question
um or are you attracted to the fact that
he has less girls around no my
ex-partner he's chubby you know I mean
who's your celebrity crush
um
there
you ain't got no belly man's six foot
eight and pure muscle that's my crush
what I what I find is most of the time
when girls like Dad bods they just and
I'm sorry I've been there I've been
there you just like that
it's something it's cute I'm not saying
I went in my base but little medium like
bitter Chop Chop it's like when girls
try to switch it up and go for them
okay I need I need to read Super Chat
actually okay so um I'm gonna read some
super chats guys thank you so much for
the super chats we want to order the 8K
camera this week we're already shooting
in 4k if you guys literally want to see
the freckles on my face send a Super
Chat also guys
um we're going to do a stream where we
have a whiteboard in the back and we're
gonna have the highest super Chats on it
so if you've if you've been the stream
sponsored the last couple of shows if
you have a message that you want me to
put on the Whiteboard email it to me
justperlythings gmail.com
um and then also whoever sponsors the
stream today whoever donates the most
will get to be the stream sponsor and
you know some times people put like
funny stuff on it okay
black is Panther if a woman chooses to
wait she has to add value to the man's
life right away do things other women
would scoff at things that would make
you hard to replace in the meantime
Jamel Allen waiting does waiting doesn't
make a difference seven days or six
months sex doesn't determine if you get
a relationship it's what you do after to
keep the man what can you bring to the
table that the next girl can't Darius
Horton if men are looking for their
mothers in relationships can't women say
that can't they say that women are
looking for their fathers in
relationships still not incest weirdo 90
free top pay um awj it's obvious then
answer the question dummy Mr raidu a
virgin makes you face the fact that
you're not ready to be a husband devious
Davis as a black man I'm going to take
the owl and say pearl where can I find a
woman with your outlook in church
question mark
um I don't know
um Anthony McLean auntie thank you a 500
Super Chat from UNC everyone's clavier
um UNC respect to the platform Auntie
was speaking truth and women must
address other women so they start moving
with proper intentions especially if
their intent is to attract a man of
value the mindset of her intention of
intentions will show up in her daily
Behavior women don't realize they're
broke broken mindset once in her daily
Behavior women don't realize they're
broke broken mindset once their body
their low their body count Rises stay
woke
mgtow by Logic why do men care about
body count don't ask because you don't
care to listen everyone's telling you
you don't care so shut up we care so it
matters because we say it does
um McLean oh shoot mcclendian Auntie
keeps speaking the truth um Zoro slot
men aren't attracted to your career
money and Status that's good for you
you're just more masculine now we want
femininity Purity Youth and Beauty Body
Count matters um Kaleo I respect the
hell out of Auntie Clifford please get
Pearl please get the I feel jar they can
never answer a straight up questions
um
please get an I feel jar they can never
give a straight up answer to simple
questions Cortez the guy screaming in
the corner is the vibe but dresses like
that Uncle that still thinks he's young
how old is he NSX
um ladies the most unattractive thing in
some woman is attitude I'd never get in
a relationship with a quarrelsome woman
who needs to be right at all costs Matt
butcher to all young ladies you proved
really early on the couch why the couch
of Shame is a thing on the show why
would any of us want you after this Duro
slot a promiscuous woman is a 304 a
promiscuous man is a 304 maker a man a
man is not your friend if you let him
try once after years he's going to take
the bait Gus if you're a single if
you're a single woman by your late 20s
and so on feminism has lied to you and
turned you into the independent
masculine men you've always wanted to
date and marry John Thiel no woman can
top my mother because I know that
everything she does for me is for my
survival any woman that comes along long
now I can that I make six figures does
any woman that comes along now that I
make six figures does things for me for
her survival you can't top it Brandon's
seat my mother was my number one woman
until I got married last year but my
wife also knows that if my mom is riding
in the car with us she jumps in the back
that's respect these young ladies need
married friends Doug MPA most black
woman in the west hate black men the
woman on the couch are all hateful and
spiteful how do you expect to get in
relationships James Sharp I'm married
there's no such thing as the one there's
no soulmate it's just the one you're
with make it work or your marriage will
fail the average Modern Woman isn't wife
material NSX congrats on 500k await 590
weight 600k Uh crap it's ticking fast
simply congratulations thank you guys
um okay so today
um going back to this topic I know we've
got a little off topic today
um I wanted to read you guys something
from the rational mail you guys know
what the rational mail is no okay okay
well
he has an article titled there is no the
one juanitis is paralysis you cease to
mature you cease to move you cease to be
you there is no one there is no soulmate
myth there are some good ones and some
bad ones but there is no one anyone
telling you anything else is selling you
something there are lots of special
someone's out there for you just ask the
divorced and widowed person who's
remarried after their soulmate has died
and moved on
what do you guys think of that statement
oh no you know that sorry
I was in Winter Wonderland just know
so the super chats took it early
this is just the beginning of the
article Oneida says paralysis you cease
to mature you cease to move you cease to
be you there is no the one there is no
soulmate women there is no soulmate myth
there are some good ones and some bad
ones but there is no one anyone telling
you anything else is selling you
something there are lots of special
someone's out there for you just ask the
divorced and widowed person who's
remarried after their soulmate has died
or moved on yeah if one man died I
wouldn't be married you wouldn't remarry
if he died I agree with the article no I
don't man some people might just be
scared of being by themselves man some
people just don't want to be alone man
I'll tell you a personal experience sure
I've been with a girl yeah and
I went away whatever then
she moved on well she got back with her
childhood like sweetheart yeah boom boom
moved on relationship marriage ring on
her finger everything yeah like kids
happy home whatever
like you see once like something happens
now yeah like a bit negative like I
still get scorned upon you know what
like there's still hatred to me you know
what I get blamed no I get blamed for
going away that that situation is with
someone yeah she must have been found in
your own there's an argument it's your
fault yeah yeah if it's not going well
it's my fault because I should be that
man you get me like I didn't you I'm
trying to say so she would like to her
you were the one yeah yeah and you were
the one that got away and it doesn't
matter who she has like yeah so with all
she's moved on and she is genuinely
happy but obviously things not again
happen to me and she ain't getting out
of it but she is but so for some reason
any type my something happens it's
mindful because I still get that like
despite because you know what if you got
your act together it should be you that
you get me put yeah
what did you say I said then she ain't
genuinely no she's genuinely happy it
goes back it goes back to
there's relativeness to the happiness
because if say like I wasn't one of her
body counts now
totally happy in that situation she
feels like she's settled yeah
if she was happy
girls do you guys think that's common
among women
wait what exactly is the question so
that situ were you listening when he
said do you think that's a common
situation where the girl is with a new
guy but she misses the old guy
I feel like that can happen if if you
have an ex and you've been with for a
certain amount of years or whatever and
then you're with a new guy and then he's
not making you feel like had other guys
feeling because you had time to do that
because you're doing for eight years so
the guy in this one month ain't sure I
knew that you might be thinking raw I
can't feel like this but times to take
that things take time to know
um
I don't think it's that common because I
feel like if a woman if a woman is truly
truly satisfied with her new partner
her ex ain't even gonna come across her
her
um mind because the new guy is bringing
more to if she's saying she's genuinely
happy it's because the new guy is
bringing something different he's
bringing something more he is doing
things that her crusty X obviously
wasn't doing so the fact that she [ __ ]
up why is it crusty amazing maybe she
[ __ ] up well well yeah okay maybe she
[ __ ] up but I'm saying like if if she
just like not obviously on about you but
generally if if the woman is generally
happy with their next part and I don't
think it's that common because I think
when when I personally think like you
know when they say like when a man
cheats like or if a woman cheats on a
guy and he's heartbroken and this and
that it's like it's very concrete for
them but like when a woman will forgive
a guy cheating a lot but when she's done
she's done and I think that's why it
can't be common because I feel like when
a woman is done with a guy she's done
with a guy but but what I found is
there's always the one that got away and
I think that's why that's why I brought
up that song that was all over the
rainbow I'm sure if I played it you guys
would hear it like yeah yeah and I'm
saying I think that resonates with women
because there's there's not I think
women move on faster than men and you're
right when she's done she's done but I I
do think there's this concept of girls
having The One That Got Away go ahead I
think it's if you it's about whether you
healed or not I think yeah you can move
on but if you haven't healed then that
will always be the one you got away but
once you truly deal with the trauma you
have from that past situationship
relationship that's when you can
move on so I'm curious when you guys
hear healing as men what does that say
to you that like I had to heal the men
put a man put you through no no no I
want to hear from them what is what is
that that mean run run why because men
ain't no therapists no but he said we
have to heal with you no you're not
there's no eating you have not eat you
think you have and as soon as men do
something oh my ex done that that's how
you probably move I'm going but that's
just a human thing to happen
Okay I wanna I wanna let the guys talk
really quick I want to hear from the
guys when you hear that what is that so
you say run yeah why though like why do
I need your [ __ ] from your previous
relationship why not bringing my
[ __ ] when does a man bring his
[ __ ] to this
relationships no a man don't do that
it's always you girl want to bring base
here until men I'm blaming for what Gary
done forgotten John Peter Paul and all
the mags in the Bible
so what about you what do you when you
hear that what do you hear I just say
instability so it's like I might lie
down with you a couple times I'm not
gonna take it so you're ready okay what
about you yeah do you know what like can
you hear healing healing needs to be
like I had to heal healing should be
done by yourself like you can't come
with me and be healing but women hardly
ever do that though so when a girl heals
they go to the club yeah that's what
that's what their friends cast them up
their friends girl you need to come out
I've just heard from guys when they hear
healing it means run through yeah
anyway man I was supposed to tell you
before my bridge
you see what you just saying in in a
relationship here for a menu the biggest
problem in that relationship is not your
girl you know if you get a crusty friend
that's got no man got no man got no man
we run through a bag of time don't know
to keep away relationship because her
attitudes stink and she just hate men
from from birth and it's telling your
girl no forget about him and then when
you leave your girl against accept
that's in life but men bring their
baggage as well when they got them
dramatic crazy baby moms or Nah serious
you just got some bad experience what
are you doing to do with kids why are
you dating
like if you if you pick someone you
cannot be mad if you and I said the same
thing to them if you pick someone that
has a child that's baggage
like it also is okay the contrary to at
that point as well when men are overly
controlling with next women I think
that's Trauma from their past
relationships like if they've been
cheated on what's controlling to you
what's controlling to me um a guy trying
to tell me what I can and cannot wear
where I can and kind of man tells me
that really yeah yeah I don't know how
you you are okay how are you okay with
you you wouldn't you really want me to
go outside in the mini skirt and this
one because no but not even like my
mentor husband when I come on the
podcast I mustn't show my knees because
of what I must be careful than what I
wear because when I step out the house
I'm representing him nah that's love
yeah I think this ain't nice
okay okay let me ask you something let
me ask you something you don't you don't
wanna wait wait wait wait wait you don't
you don't you don't want to be with a
guy that you have like you don't want to
be with a guy that you have to listen to
like you don't want to be with a guy
who's judgment you trust
um to tell me what I kind of kind of
like tells me that my head is big
head and I need to I need to lose
but that's not so when it suits you you
wanna imagine
10 pounds from a guy from a guy's point
of view that's really hard for them to
work with because like to the to a guy
when a guy hears that it's like to me
who cares like why does it it's not
gonna affect my life that much what I
wear when I go out of the house and I
want to be I want to be with a guy whose
judgment that I trust right so it's like
when a guy hears that he just hears that
you won't cooperate with him that you're
hard to work with that you that you
you're stubborn he's just throwing his
toys out of camera
again most most guys want a girl that
will submit to him and Trust his
judgment right would you agree with that
yeah so so if his judgment and he says
hey you know what I don't want there to
be problems could you change your time
like your boobs are out or whatever it
is and you say well but like that's a
headache to him no but it's not about
what you're describing is a conversation
and I think as though if you have a
conversation you say oh you know what
you're wearing I can't I don't like it
I'll be like Fez at least we're having a
conversation about it you're not coming
at me but even but even even but even if
he just says it even if he just says hey
change your top of course yeah that's
fine but it's not like he's not he's not
like oh my God
he's telling you what to do in that
instance that's what she didn't say that
he said a dumb but he said it's
controlling to tell me what I can and
cannot wear so if he says change your
top like to me I think I think it's sexy
when a guy when a guy has standards
I think it's I think it's attractive I
agree and so when a guy hears that you
won't do it that's a small thing to him
that's why I Got Crystal a few yeah so
when Gertrude Gertrude yeah and Gertrude
and Patrick is still together from 1901
yeah and Patrick Patrick been telling
Gertrude Gertrude don't show your knee
gertrice is not sure this knee but
they're still together and he went for
Gertrude for five years to buy Gertrude
because you know Gertrude was a good
girl I met with me for three months okay
can I can I can I just say something
what's your name young man Rick Rick can
I just say something
on enough
all the hard times or whatever him tell
him what to do and me doing what he
tells me what to do him telling me that
my head is big and telling me that my
cheeks look like two slaps of lever that
I need to lose some weight him telling
me four weeks late and you know what 32
years I'm coming
there you go because Gertrude listen
just you know what I'm saying you I'm
mad you know why what's a man tell you a
baby I bet you just cover your boobs of
politically what's wrong with that is it
is it is it out there for a display
Spider-Man to be like what are you
saying baby or is it isn't it and in
general in general yeah 1901 I'm pretty
sure there was more marriages than than
now and then another thing yeah happy
marriages
a lot of abusive marriages
most grandparents ask them about their
marriage yeah I wasn't finished I wasn't
finished but most grandparents in
general are happily married the majority
of grandparents is when it gets to our
appearance that's when it kind of starts
bringing the majority of grandparents
are happily married and let me just flip
it quickly here you see as a woman that
all right so you see how much you look
Social Circles now yeah you see like the
women that are like with partners that
in relationships so you see like you are
going out you got that one friend that
she's in a relationship but she's at
every turn up with you every turn up
wearing what she wants she's the last
one on the dark so hey you're not
thinking all right you got a man no but
then but then there's a one there's the
ones that is in a relationship like I
would I would think girls would see it a
little bit better that oh like her man
comes after The Raven and picks her up
and she kind of carry you've noticed
that since she's been in a relationship
she kind of carries herself a little bit
different like she ain't like every turn
up she'll come at that birthdays but not
every turn up it's a little bit
different like and while you're shaking
waiting for Uber waiting for the man to
pull up in the phone like her man's
there outside and picking up and going
in with her like there's other little
things going on don't you I don't know
can I ask you freeze would I I agree
with you so much okay I agree with you I
don't get what's the question no but
what I said is it's been I'm just it's
going off of what Paul said about um
black when if a man says to you so I
feel like oh change change your clothes
that don't wear that or whatever yeah so
I'm flipping it I'm saying like because
it's a way over
um how a man interacts with his woman
within a relationship here so I'm saying
amongst your Social Circle don't you see
the difference in how like the good
things in what a good man will put into
his woman amongst your friends in your
Social Circle in terms of like not being
at every turn up they've kind of
selectively pull up now and when they
pull up it's a bit different they're not
as out there as it as they was before
they're just a little bit more you know
what I mean and more time afterwards
they're getting picked up that the man's
out there picking them up so don't you
you don't respect yeah she's like I want
yeah no I feel like I feel like
obviously as a single woman or while
you're outside getting grabbed yeah but
I feel like it's all up to the woman of
her she wants to act did you understand
so I feel like as a single woman if
you're outside doing XYZ XYZ it's going
to be different to if you're in a
relationship I'm not in a relationship
right now but where I see it going with
the person I'm talking to right now
would I be out there with Tia and batia
and rare tear but if I was single not to
say that I wouldn't have my ticket but
if I'm wearing a pair of short shorts
and I'm going to the club or the
festival or wherever I'm going I'm not
gonna think oh right I'm wearing this
because I like this but if I have a
boyfriend I'm leaving a door he's like
you know what baby like you're battling
that's for me when we're behind clothes
I don't want your webinar I would I
would take that um
what are you wearing but you're going
out like that but I want to do it
because I want to do lots of perspective
on Eula as the single woman looking your
perspective when you're looking on your
friend that's now her relationship state
is his chain now she's got a man do you
not look on that and see how she's gonna
think yeah like and I think it's true
because I'm not gonna lie a lot of times
I've been in a relationship and there's
there's a red eye friend yeah
because all the time when I was changing
my outfit turning down on my language
cutting down on my drinking not wearing
skirts up to my ass oh even though
you're slim enough to wear it
all my friends had issues with me oh
he's doing it even now he's doing this
he's doing that I know what no they
never got a man
they'll be doing the same I've had not
more men in that one time the iPad none
of them even got a man they're miserable
especially my sister they're miserable
misery
they're just miserable you know what
because they're always going to turn
around and say oh yeah she's got a man
but you know what because they're
miserable leftovers
in relationships they don't they still
will come out or they will marry us
um no I don't have any friends right now
it doesn't really count unless they've
been in the relationship how does it not
but Auntie how long you been are you
married I'm a leftover woman I've got a
ring I was supposed to ring so I'm just
the same as used like this I got more
self-respect it wasn't about coming up
it was about how they act when they come
here yeah but when they died that's what
I was gonna say all my friends act the
same they don't act any different and
they still will go out wearing to eat
and okay
I've got one friend that's been with her
man for seven years submissive months
but he
is
okay but he's not insecure
now with her with with whatever she
feels like she wants to I'm not saying
though just just my final point is I'm
not saying that if a woman goes out and
like she's wearing something where her
vagina lips are hanging out or it's
really revealing that that's okay like
if I was doing that of course and my mom
was like no then yeah because it looks
scary but I'm saying if I wanted to wear
my cleavage out and stuff like that and
he said no I would think he's trying to
control me okay okay watch it listen
here I'm gonna say something to you
live your life the way you want to live
your life with your teaching them out
leave your bomb cheeks out when you're
alone in 15 blood years time but what
makes you makes you think I'll be alone
listen because listening no dumb [ __ ]
let some do some ways
finally yeah
listen let me ask something when you're
selling the house you put a sign outside
right yeah so why you need to walk
around with a sign you're selling are
you doing
um
I'm actually a question I'm asking you a
question in it yeah and I said you do
put outside if you want if you want to
attract ants you put you put sugars down
right someone else is going to come
along right no but women don't wear it
to attract men that's [ __ ]
okay come on shut up like stop it so
it's just it's disingenuous if a girl
has her tits out if your girl has her
tits out in a mini skirt you how could
you say you don't want attention because
if I go out in sweats I know nobody's
looking at you if I go out in a mini
skirt with my boobs out and it's so it's
it's like okay
if a guy if a guy walked out in a clown
outfit and then was confused and people
said look that's a clown if you walk out
looking like a hoe and every
think his wife's a hoe
history
but I've gone out wearing the titty
summer looking righteous is all looking
good I've gone to a gay club like that
where it's just pure lesbians
no I haven't got a man that's right
with sexy Minds no one is woman walking
out with all her titties out the door no
I've been gay clubs and even if it was a
gay club I still won't go gay club with
all my titties hanging out because some
lesbian's gonna go for me because my
titties look good so I want to have them
out on show and when you said the one
thing I don't like about women is that
when I when a woman's saying about her
man takes expecting as she is they turn
around and say the man's insecure my man
and insecure my man just respects me and
wants me to respect myself and to
respect my body and to respect him so
because my man is telling me Oh he don't
like that when I'm going out with my
dress all up my ass it doesn't make him
insecure right because he's not gonna
get a man and he'll be an alpha man and
he use that one only is out for men and
then when the man put something in place
you saying that you're insecure and
that's why the women that they're single
because you don't want no one to tell
you nothing you don't want to go out
with your titties hanging titties
swinging ass hanging and swinging and
use that thing you know what we're all
independent we can do what we like I
don't mind can tell us anything because
we're inside it's all about having
self-respect for you your man your body
and society that you're in but I do
respond titties are there for two kind
of people you're meant to suck on and
your babies are suffering the titties
are not there for everybody
to eat your food you don't go in the
street in the cup and say I'm gonna eat
my food in front of everyone so when
your man's sucking in your titties there
for him only okay and you can be out
there sharing to everybody and here's
the other thing it's like men just want
a girl that's easy to get along with and
so if you're arguing and he can't tell
me what to do it's controlling like like
stop and it's a headache to men it's a
headache go ahead I got one question for
you and be honest you don't blood clot
like to me you know
are you gonna get upset
what you're saying here is right for you
you're correct for you what he's given
you is the man's the perspective this is
what you're not understanding so what
you're seeing you're within your rack
you're single you're within your rights
to have your titties out have your
battery whatever your within your rights
you get me you look good go on with your
thing but hey what now there's a
consequence yeah but for every action
there's a reaction so when you look good
you're gonna and it's out side you're
gonna attract more you see what I'm
trying to say so what he's saying is
like he's putting the perspective of it
from a man if a man if a man sees that
you're gonna look he's gonna look it you
see what I'm trying to say so obviously
what you're saying about you don't want
attention but the consequence for you
the the reaction for you acting like
that you will get attention but I feel
like that's anyway yeah
I feel like in today's day and age women
need to take responsibility for their
own actions you know what I mean like if
you want to go out what's addressing how
you want to dress fine you can do
whatever you want you know what I mean
but
if you get unwanted attention if you get
guys grabbing you on the street you're
walking trying to walk to a cab and
you've got guys running after you doing
this that any other you can't be shot
yeah because you're putting everything
out on show and you're advertising a
certain way and and you're trying you're
attracting a certain type of man you're
like if you're dressed a certain way
like everyone knows it after the club
yeah all of the wolves are out they're
all looking they're looking to take
something home yeah if you're if you're
standing on the street waiting for a cab
and you've got your teaser and your
asset the wolves are coming
because because they're looking at you
like yes easy you know what I mean but
but a lot of a lot of women will be like
why are you coming to me you can't be
doing this you can't be doing that but
you got to take responsibility so I mean
like if if if I if I went to if I went
to the worst estate in London wearing
jewels watch this that and the other
like I I can I can do what I want I can
wear what I want but there's
consequences you know I mean and so I
feel like women these days need to
actually understand the consequences to
their actions like we don't live in an
Ideal World you know I mean like like we
live in reality we live in a real world
I have a question do you dress different
when you're single and when you're in a
relationship no I don't and I never have
that's why you're single do you know
what you know what like so I'm single
because I wear what I want no I'm saying
like why would you advertise to to me
like like why do you need that attack if
you know you look good right and so you
want a dress to look good and you want
to dress reveal and dress revealing
right to me that's an advertisement
that's saying to men look at me because
men always look unless you're in like a
plastic bag right always what I'm saying
when I'm in my gym stuff I'm wearing a
big baggie no face okay I'm with you I
agree but I'm saying you're gonna
attract would you say you attract more
attention when you're dressed up super
nice boobs out ass out oh yeah 100 so
when you have a man why would you want
to attract unwanted attention but it's
not a thing like that like my thought
process when I can only speak for myself
obviously but when I'm dressed in how I
want it's not a thought process where
I'm thinking oh I'm dressing revealing
because I want to get attention but I'm
saying like men want a girl that's
considerate and that's being considerate
it's thinking oh you know what he might
not like that I'm getting all this
attention everywhere and you know
because I have a man I'm going to be
considerate but it's like if it could be
flipped on the same side with a woman
I notice it's one thing whenever I make
a point about woman we always have to
flip it on the men this is just a point
about women because I'm sorry men and
women it's not the same
no girls looking at men the same way
that men look at women we're Beauty
right and it's you know it's not the
same so I think we're constantly coming
from why do we never hold it but we
always hold on it's not a man walking
about looking sexy with his balls
hanging out you know I mean guys
men are trash that's common in society
right women are trash isn't men are held
accountable all the time every day
no we're at a low we offer less demand
than ever the average age of first men
value Purity in youth yeah Purity youth
Beauty women are fatter than ever before
we're older than ever before and we're
less youthful than ever getting married
and we have more bodies than ever so so
we bring less to the table than ever how
many women have a cookbook
of just recipes that they made
themselves how many women have that that
you know
what's her name the French Nigella
Lawson okay
you're thinking your own recipes that
you've written in there that can't stand
wait what do you mean yeah
how many women have a cookbook how many
women know how to do it how many women
are neat and organized domesticated how
many men can build stuff how many men
um can fix up at home
not all men can say that dude
let's just do it let's just do all right
do any do any of you have a cookbook of
recipes you've written yourself Auntie
any of you I can I can cook a lot of it
I said do you have recipes that have
been passed down generation to
generation
name five
um we have a special fried rice that we
cook we have fish stew um African we
have a cookbook we have recipes how many
of you are virgins
[Music]
this is what men care about like the
ideal woman for most men is a virgin 20
22 year old roughly that are most
attracted to 22 year olds right you know
honestly there's some data that says
younger some some says 18 some says even
younger so let's not go let's go with
22. you can actually say something right
just to um
my man when I was growing up I was in a
dance group with this girl
and this girl was the most sexiest hot
girl and he always went on about her and
I went out with I went I met her over
the couple of weekends ago and I said
yeah I saw your girl he goes oh she
looks so hot
you know I mean and I showed him a
picture of her not a video it went awful
he said to me do you know what right
you've upset me all the next day he was
talking about it I couldn't sleep all
the next day she went from like a 68
year old to like a size 20 well
and he couldn't believe that it's the
same person I said I look a lot better
in your eyes now didn't I but I never
had no problem with him looking at other
women
because I know that we're coming into my
Oasis that was your crush back then
that's why I was happy to show him
that women let themselves go they've
always got so much to talk about the men
but when they get to a certain age they
let themselves go on the splits but to
get the same men yep well it's nine
times out don't keep up they don't keep
up the energy they don't keep it up no
no no fake it women women they default
of that put it this way here when we was
all in school there wasn't
AE 19 20 year old women pulling up in
cars to pick up the yeah
there was a 19 year old men putting on
cars to pick up the hottest year 10 year
11 go that that so it just goes to show
women 100 they Peak earlier and then how
many times have you seen like for the
menu like within your friendship groups
and whatnot there was that girl that for
certain man wasn't attainable in school
yeah she was like I said the AE 19 year
old was picking up all the or the bad
issue in school
but fast forward down the line like at
24 25. all of a sudden she's following
you and she's she's showing
interested because she's lost the things
men value now because she's probably
older she's probably fatter and she's
probably slept with more dips
yeah and you've caught because you've
gained more value yeah and but that's
we're so brainwashed that we literally
think like women we literally think
we're the prize when we offer less than
ever but what's the whole thing with
Factor like you've said fatter a few
times like
women that's not true then why does
every rich man have a Victoria's Secret
model or someone that looks like one but
they still cheat but they still cheats
guys cheating isn't winning the winning
is the girl that gets the ring and the
girl that gets the deed it's not winning
just because just because you got a dude
to sleep with you guys will sleep with a
hole Yeah that's not a that's not a
prize
the fat but I just think it's a lack of
discipline that when you see somebody's
overweight you've got to think to
yourself because everybody gets caught
up whenever you say whenever you mention
the word fat and there's somebody fat
around some most of the time they always
get a fence to it but you can only say
like you said if you're fat you're fat
no no no no no let me finish because the
women it always seems to think like oh
yeah
lack of discipline
that's what the men are seeing they're
not saying oh yeah you got a bit of what
they're thinking well I'm gonna she
can't control it because you control
money because you control herself
because she control and that's what
they're thinking about because the
biggest sign I don't care whether people
say oh they eat they're sick they're
this they're they're whatever they
whatever they were ever it's like a
discipline bill got fat
I see Pearl going out there and doing
the gym and they know having a talk
today about more not more protein less
carbs and all that so
as far as I'm concerned she's trying to
do something about it even though she
got cut back on all them cupcakes but
she's she's gonna he's gonna make us
suffer for it
he's gonna make her suffer for it but me
now I got the same clothes
as when my son was young and what I find
to realize now is that I tried on the
dress the other day and it looked like
it was swallowing me I'm a size eight
the dress is a size eight and what I
realized now is that when I'm seeing
these fat people say oh yeah I'm a size
10 I forget you can't be a size 10. you
know what because the people that are
making the clothes are making a size 10
bigger so me now I can go in certain
places and I have to buy a size four or
a size six I'm not a size four and a
size six I'm a size eight to ten granted
to say that's what you are now you know
what I mean but if that's the case then
you've got the people there that
normally 14 and 16 and they're saying
they're size 12. but that's what men
that women always say oh they're always
saying that we're fat you know what
cause a men say as I lack of discipline
the main thing is like you cannot be
cooking good home cooked food and being
that size
I feel like what do you not agree with a
lot with what Auntie saying at all
because I feel like there are men out
there that okay there are men out there
that don't care about the size and there
are men out there that specifically go
for bigger gods they are men out there
that even are feeders they purposely
okay okay
like fat women I get it obviously being
fat is not in society it's not seemed as
being attractive but however I don't
think it's fair to say what what percent
of guys I don't know statistics no I'm
saying like come on let's just be like
let's just be real for a second yeah
let's be real what percent of guys is
that common men to be like this is what
girls always do it's every time we make
a point that's for the men and that
makes sense we have to bring up the
exception if if that was the case then
you would see the men with the most
options the most handsome men and the
most rich men with fat chicks but
they're not but the men no the men that
date fat the men that date fat chicks
it's usually they don't have as many
options and some girls get away with it
a little bit more because they're shaped
better they have a pretty face but by
and large men just don't like fat girls
would you go to the chicken shop and buy
a bone and a bit of chicken with no meat
on it
would you go to the chicken shop and ask
for a side rest with no meat they might
like ass and booze but they don't want a
gun that's the ultimate for like chicken
back yes I do but then if you like to do
you go to chicken back to chicken
breasts do you go to the chicken shop to
buy chicken with no meat on it no you
don't you want some meat on your chicken
okay
that comparison makes no sense
I've heard like like in from what I can
hear and see it's like the common
problem today is that
the young women of this generation they
think they know what men want and they
say with such like such convictions
that's conviction but you just need to
listen and ask a bit more because
there's men in the room there's men
within your life like yeah you you can't
truly say you you know what a man wants
because quite clearly in almost every
time you've been wrong so no no we only
based off of what men say because men
are the ones
okay okay do you would you do you think
it's any validity that these are all
random dudes that I barely know barely
that random so this is at random so if
they give you an answer and it's all the
same would you say that says something
about men so I'm gonna ask them I don't
know what they're gonna say I don't know
them I can't influence them I would say
that a lot of men follow each other's
mentality right so they don't speak that
on June I don't think they speak their
real food and I'm gonna follow up and
say as well there's like men that that
deep down they love big girls but
they're embarrassed to show it because
they're mandem their group don't like
big girls so if they speak up and say
well I like it like you just said you
like big girls that's real because most
guys will follow what each other man
says and I feel like maybe maybe like I
feel like early 2000's 100 being thick
being even my size like obviously I'm a
bigger girl in it I don't think I'm fat
other people might think I'm fat but I
know I'm I'm a bigger guy don't worry no
no but I'm not saying it like that I'm
just saying I'm like you said be real so
I know what people would think about me
but I know I think about myself but but
now I'm talking now I'm back in the day
yeah you're right being fat was a No-No
but if we're talking now it's like it's
completely flipping they're making songs
about it yeah because girls want to
girls want to be brain like this is the
thing they brainwash us this is what
they're doing they're making you think
that men like fat chicks I'm telling you
I've talked to hundreds hundreds of men
if they have a choice between a girl
with a big ass big boobs and small waist
or a good a girl with a gut and both
they're
sorry one second Auntie yeah just let me
finish this but what I'm saying is men
that means men are chatting [ __ ] because
online now all you see is I want to go
with a fupa because I want to go with
with I wanna I wanna okay you got like
who has more social media men or women
social media is for women it is for
women they Pander to us together it is
for absolutely four women women make 70
to 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions they're trying to sell you
something
that's what they're doing she knows
something right people just need to come
off people just need to come off social
media because
you got real men here in the flesh
telling you what they like and you're
saying she said yeah but online well
yeah but she's saying but online they
tell me you cannot see guys on like guys
online Gaslight okay
do you guys like fat chicks if so how
fat no I don't no no it's not it's not
my preference okay but I've slept with
one experience have an experience but no
okay
would you date a girl bigger than you
I'm bigger than me yeah no because I'm
going down okay okay I was I was a very
small guy just got big but I'm going
back down now okay okay so all right a
girl let's say let's say 200. what 200
200 too fat
yeah
a girl you a girl you take out in public
sleeping with doesn't count you have to
take her out in public
okay my girlfriend here you can't my
mother would have a problem with that
I'm never gonna lie still okay okay one
170.
and what's that installed
foreign 150.
what's that in Stones man [ __ ] do you
know
sorry you need to turn my thing up big
dog okay but but in general no bigger
than you smaller than you
okay all right then let's do sizing
close 14 16 18 20.
oh Mommy why man I could have pressure
all right okay okay so you said no fat
girls you said maybe this is chunky 12
okay and
no no
no but it doesn't add blessing yes or no
blessing all right we're gonna just one
more guy
okay I actually wanted to add more I
wanted to go on go ahead go ahead go
ahead go ahead adding on to what Auntie
said this sorry it's not even just about
like look it's about the health thing
you know especially if you want to be
able long-term you've got to think
diabetes you've got to think like the
heart rate you gotta think even just
basic stuff like
her being able to see her toes like well
because if you're a fat you're gonna
have health problems someone's got to
take care well this is what I'm saying
he's being nice it boils down to
Lifestyle don't it like like me I'm an
active guy go to the gym so for me I
need my girl to be going to the gym yes
I said discipline he's being nice yeah
he's as a man yeah
see the whole stuff yeah cool that's
yeah you may be doing it to drop dead
but I never I tell you a big thing what
man think about you dying is yummy and a
woman that's like borderline you even
breatheter yeah she even breathing when
the baby and hear what I'm saying the
comfortability of of me can know your
woman there's a certain comfortability
where inevitably she's gonna gain a
couple because nowadays that you're off
the market so this is why we're women
say they don't do nothing typically when
you're off the market you're getting a
couple when
but in general so guys think about that
so if you already borderline yeah the
average with every kid it's like 30
pounds on average which is which it
shouldn't be but that's that's what it
is in the west okay can I just drop
something can I just drop some games
listen yeah that's straight well women
we're mums and say yeah I reckon she
might always say that if you want to see
what your future
I thought I was the only man
I'm gonna drop some game for you girls
yeah look women control sex men
controlled marriage in it so at the end
of the day you can sleep with as many
guys as you want but the guys that you
want you need to conform to what they
actually want so you have to listen to
what men actually want you know I mean
like
of my girl managed to get me locked down
because I met her she was submissive she
cooked clean anything I needed she did
it
finished cooking he takes the plate away
and that's I I don't have to do anything
I go to I go to a flat I just sit there
and that's I don't have to do anything
she just she just wants to serve me look
after me do everything she goes to the
gym keeps herself looking fit she
listens to me if we go out for dinner or
something and I don't know what she's
wearing she comes out and I give her I
don't even say anything if I if I if I'm
not looking at her going I love that
she's like I'm gonna go change
like because she's just she wants my
approval you know I mean so so that is
what men want really because me I don't
need to look elsewhere no more you know
what I mean so that is what men want and
and women are so hard-headed that they
don't want to listen to that because
they want to just believe this they want
to wear what they want to wear yeah it's
not a weakness
you're doing too much no it's a strength
because I know what they're going to say
why can't you quote for yourself why
does a woman have to cook for you why
does it women can't cook but they don't
feed that men could cook for themselves
and the woman is choosing to cook for
you
why aren't you telling her she makes all
these choices you're insecure because
from the time a man's telling the woman
that she needs to lose weight or she's
too fat you're insecure what she's doing
is you're saying it's not her being
submissive you're treating her like it's
a choice and she and my girl makes these
choices because she knows it's going to
make me happy and her priority is just
to make me happy because making me happy
he's gonna make her happy because the
happier I am
I have a question for the guy really
quick we're going to finish out the show
because it's getting kind of late but I
just I'm curious because someone super
chatted this
um you pick a girl with 55 bodies
or a girl with three bodies and a kid
who you picking my buddies what 55 55
bodies
you're gonna come back to me you know
that's a bad one oh this three three and
a three oh how many three in a kid three
bucks and a kid one kid yeah one kid
I'll pick the three buddies man
YouTube YouTube
[Laughter]
No but the kid comes with a baby dad as
well okay let's say a daughter no the
baby
a kid comes with a baby okay I just got
it what is your gut saying you gotta
pick one one two three which one they
beat that drama what take the kid you
take the character I'm not taking the
YouTuber I'll take the kids
but you know what makes a difference is
what what what situation was that kid on
was it what did the kid come from a
relationship or just a bank that makes a
difference the crazy baby fathers
hanging around the back yeah but that'll
bother me like Barefoot wouldn't you
right wouldn't you wouldn't you rather
than one night stand though because it's
the relationship the guy might just be
hanging around more if that because it's
still free bodies so I would rate them
more like there's context to bodies that
if you got like
five bodies and
but but like you've had free
relationships four relationships I still
rate that much it just makes a
difference to me okay so you you said
because
okay okay
you take the single mother you would
take the bodies definitely 100 that is
okay
50 50. okay okay guys um it's it's
getting late so we're going to close out
the show
um why don't we go around everyone
um
say any final thoughts you have if you
have any social media or Brands you want
to plug you can do it now so start here
go around and then the second row so go
ahead
um I don't have final thoughts yeah but
um follow my Tick Tock Sharon Dotson
okay
um yeah I think it was really good to
show you in a chat and I feel like it
was really interesting to hear
everyone's different opinions and my
Instagram is
k-a-t-r-e-n-a dot w and my business
plays for models is p-o-x-y-m-o-d-e-l-s
um yeah it was interesting to hear
conflicting opinions definitely usually
I don't like to have these sort of
conversations where it's good to hear
realism from everyone so thank you for
this
um yeah so follow me on all my socials
at night's world
nyswrldxo and tune in to my radio show
every Monday GMT UK time 9 A.M till 11AM
on represent radio you have a radio I
was thinking thank you very much have a
reason yeah is that a good lead yeah
that's a good thing
uh for all you men looking to get your
bid right uh shout out beard gang
members good yeah listen we make
miracles happen bad gang members on all
socials bigmembers.com
yeah social media hurricane 3.0 uh March
March come watch me box at the
Tabernacle West London
big dog yeah VIP tickets
under your channels in the description
just so you guys know you should go
subscribe yeah because I don't know what
they are anyway they're going to take
they're going to take clips from this so
I know me freaking out again I gotta say
that all I'm happy about is that I
normally meet those of like what I call
Sons but
I'm taking this one on I've taken I like
her so I'm going to take her yeah you're
talking about young lady I'm gonna talk
to you I'm taking you as my mom
everybody yeah I like it so I'm gonna
I'm gonna so whoever's worried about her
right I got her back I'm looking after
her right because everybody's concerned
about you out there they're worried
about you so I've got her back
yeah Instagram just called j-u-s-c-o
underscore Glo
um I think for today's show I think is
probably like I think it's better for
the women than the men because I feel
like I don't know hopefully next time
the men get a bit more at a critique
because critique is good because you get
to know what men want you get me I want
to kind of know more the other side now
what do men do wrong and you know I'm
trying to say so I could get more out oh
you want to come into my shirt I just
have an old man she's gonna she's gonna
we're gonna do wife school and husband
school okay yeah so if you guys are
Auntie Jenny's gonna help coach it we're
going to be bringing in wives and
husbands across the world I feel like we
gave lots of game but again
have they listened that's the question
okay okay sign up for husband school
coming in Spring
let me get my beard first
go ahead yeah listen I love being
anywhere chatting to people anyway but
yeah you can follow me at Rick 20jb and
all my socials and also I got YouTube
channel ptbm TV so subscribe check it
out do a lot of [ __ ] in there we'll have
fun yeah okay guys um thank you for
watching and thank you for 600k honestly
guys I could not do it without you a
couple announcements before we close out
the show the first being that we have
two clips channels Pearl daily and just
pearly Clips
um the second is that sign up for our
membership tiers the first tier you get
to be a part of the live chat on all
shows second tier you get to be part of
our Discord and you get behind the
scenes blogs third tier you get to
connect with me on social media this
means you have access to my inbox fourth
tier um you get to do a one-on-one call
with me once a month I'm actually really
good at helping people grow YouTube
channels I don't mean to brag but
basically anyone to help turns into
YouTube Gold I have helped people get to
100 000 subscribers 50 000 subscribers
10 000 subscribers I've done it and I
will do it again you will honestly get
your money back with the one session on
top of that go follow my Instagram
just.pearlythings
um it is Shadow band right now so you
have to type out the same thing same
thing with my Tick Tock they took away
my first second third and fourth Tick
Tock account so now it's just
pearlythings.5 and Dot six so go follow
both of those subscribe to the channel
if you want to be on the show um we're
actually between recruiters right now so
I don't actually know who to message
yeah just just message me or message
Auntie like